Four three, two, one.
So we get here and young Jamie is obsessed
with whether or not Leonardo Davinci
is gay and uh, so he says it
the Cowan and then Callan says,
he said the Mona Lisa,
the Mona Lisa has a
mischievous smile on her face.
And apparently according
to art historians,
I believe that is a self portrait.
And that was Davinci himself in drags.
This is a conspiracy and that's why he
is looking back at you with sort of a rye
smirk. I don't see that rise.
Smart Young. Jamie, please pull up.
This photo graph is a masterpiece. No,
this is, I think this, this is real.
I think this is, um, at least
Dan Brown in his book. Uh,
the Da Vinci Code actually talks about it,
but I I,
this is the standard talking about
the topic movies. Yes. Good. Well,
better bumper. That was a different
thing than the middle man.
I think he's a professor of theology in,
at Harvard or he or something like
that. Okay. I don't see a sly smile.
I see. Here's a check who lives in a
place where the food sucks and her,
her teeth are probably all fucked
up is often that dick smile row.
Here's an interesting thing.
Do you know that like people did
at bad teeth back then of course,
but the majority of the teeth problems
that we have in this country have to do
with sugar. I thought it was the, the
water, the fluoride in the water. No,
Florida in the water. That fluoride
in the water thing is so sketchy.
Have you ever looked into whether or
not fluoride should be in the water?
Well they,
I know the fifties,
Colorado had a high concentration of
fluoride in its water and apparently the
Sweden turns to the find out.
I know
if I could get my poker, I'm going to
poke at the uh, at the board. But I think,
I think it came out of Colorado where
there was high concentrations of fluoride
in the water. And then what
happened was they go, well,
there's a cluster of people
who are not getting cavities.
And so apparently fluoride is
effective at keeping cavities and bay.
And I grew up overseas,
my teeth to fucking tear or hole goals.
I had fuck his, you eat sugar?
What? Well, not so much overseas,
but I,
I uh,
I definitely didn't brush my teeth a lot
and I didn't have fluoride. Well, let's,
let's Google whether or not there's
evidence that fluoride is good for tooth
decay. The good thing,
because all marketing hype
from crest, I don't know man,
I've read too many hippie articles.
The problem at the Hippie Arby's refuse
you because it'll say like natural news
letter through like Colin Shit.
You don't know man,
because there's people that are get like
Oh homeopathic on you and you're like,
okay, is this guy right? Like I'm reading,
I'm going to go through 5,000 words here
am I, is he right or is this horse shit?
Am I going to, okay, now I gotta
look up the actual studies.
Okay.
Now I gotta read this three times cause
I'm stupid and I can't figure out how to
you. Let's say for it, no evidence
that fluoridated water causes cavities,
reduces cavities, rather
Macola. Now that's a one.
Now I've posted articles from mercola.com
and people go, oh, that guy's amazing.
And then other people go though that
guy's a fraud. It's tough to figure out.
I've read some stop on Doctor Mercola.
You read just like the
same kind of stopped and he
seems to be pretty like he's
a doctor, but that doesn't mean he's
an expert on to the gay or on, uh, on,
on looking at the hard evidence behind
it to the American Dental Association,
Florida and Water I field,
they must have some seven
years of scientific research.
You guys are lucky at.
He's not here. Oh yeah, saint
right now. Shit. He's on a,
an evolution kick now more than 70 years
of scientific research has consistently
shown that an optimal level of fluoride
in community water is safe and effective
in preventing tooth decay.
Safe is a scary word. Why?
Why would you be worried about that
by at least 25% of all children,
adults simply by drinking water.
Americans can benefit from flora cavity
protection without not their homework or
school centers for Disease Control,
control and prevention named
community water fluoridation.
One of tain 10 great public health
achievements of the 20th century. Okay,
now go to the one that says there's
no evidence because I got out.
Who the fuck is right here?
But I would suggest that it's
been around a long timelines,
says it ain't hit her. It has
been, but that was what I mean.
Remember what the food pyramid used to
look like. It was all like spaghetti
preview
by the cup.
Collaboration found water fluoridation
may not prevent cavities in a review of
every fluoridation study they could find.
[inaudible] I dunno the Cochran,
let me finish talking. I know you
guys like to talk over each other,
but let's trying to totally do bro.
Um,
view of every fluoridation
study they could find.
Only three studies since 1975 look at the
effectiveness of water fluoridation at
reducing tooth decay among the general
population and had high enough quality to
be included.
The studies found fluoridation does
not reduce cavities to is statistically
significant degree in permanent teeth in
the two studies since 1975 that examine
the effectiveness of fluoridation and
reduce reducing cavities in baby teeth.
No significant reduction
was noted there either.
You know what I'm thinking right now?
You know it's gone on in my head was
crying my head right now as I go.
I'm thinking this is why Google is
not a place to go for information.
A little bit true job have to be
discerning. You have to. You have to.
This is what peer reviewed
papers are so important.
This is why it was like
really valuable journalists,
scientific journalists especially
are important. That's right.
That's fucking morons like us.
We don't know who's right.
We just said something
and people go, well, no,
what so I feel like we have
to get to the bottom of this,
although I think that's, give them all
the mythbusters, some shit. My dentist,
we map the three of us,
you guys know got to the bottom
to the bottom. You can kind of look
at general trends. Like I said to my,
I had all this metal in my teeth, right?
And my dentist, I was like, look man,
I got to get it out cause you know,
leaks, mercury and, and he said,
I know I was on the,
I was on that study panel and
if you look at the massive,
the massive number of people
that have metal in their mouth,
you'd have,
you would be able to draw some pretty
broad based conclusions because you have
such a huge human yeah.
Pool. And they just haven't,
they looked at the don't do a
lot of comprehensive studies.
Same dentist who said your
teeth are straight. Uh, no,
this is a different one and I'm wearing
my Invisalign so I'd appreciate it if
you wouldn't go through my teeth. How
does, they're going to be an amazing,
we're at night. I'm wearing them
right now. And you can't tell.
I remember when Tom Cruise is like
15 and he got braces. I was like, Yo,
what are you doing? They came in because
he knows. He's like, you don't hit my bed.
Changes his voice. Do you remember?
Wait a minute, did he do that?
He went with veneers.
They're brilliant.
Steve are so veneers are amazing.
That's what I'm saying, Bro. Amazing.
I had a friend,
she did it.
One of the girls that I did news
radio with almost hit her name. Well,
I'll get us to three for
one deal up in a forefront.
One Jamie wants to keep lungs. If you
look at the good ones, you're like,
God damn you teeth are fucking fantastic.
No there that Bam Tom Cruise. What? Look,
I don't know if that is a veneers or
braces come because he did wear braces.
Look,
it has real teeth to look at the left.
I think there is real teeth and I
think the one on the left is just,
it could be shopped. I don't remember them
being that bad. I think it's Photoshop.
Yeah,
see that's why he's wearing braces.
Real ta do look for it.
I think those are his real teeth.
Go to him before braces to go to him.
Go to him smiling in the color of money
cause he was a really young in that
movie, Taco Tom Cruise,
color of money smiling.
She's such a nice Tom Cruise is a monster.
I just watched the color of money on a
flight. It was fucking crazy right there.
The far left, far left. Holy Shit.
Yeah, those are his teeth bro.
He just gathers those frontline.
Those front ones have been knocked out
and those, those are fake. There's no, no,
no. This is a long time ago man.
This is, this is the color of money.
This is like 1986 and I'm saying the
rest of the teeth or the color yellow and
the middle ones are white,
but that's hard to tell.
You seem dark shadows all over the place.
You can't really gauge yellow right there.
Look at that.
It's so hard to huge his teeth look
like that. I've seen all those books,
gentlemen.
You can't even see his right eye judging
whether or not that's his teeth color.
You can literally can't see his right
eye because he's in so much shafts.
Teeth don't look super suspect. Do you
know they look like teeth right there.
You crazy. That's his teeth. His
teeth normal. His teeth were,
you're judging by today's standards.
That's the problem.
They make those teeth perfect like that
dude. If you act bad teeth back then,
if you had fake teeth, they look fake
as fuck. That's true. He, his teeth,
his teeth were off center like
you know where the middle teeth,
they were all kind of
pushed over to the right. Now they're
way better. That's why smiling,
crooked 56 still doing an action.
Movies still does his own stunts jumps
from building to building breaks his
ankle and filming. Have you
seen that shit? No. Apparently
it's mission impossible.
Movie is a motherfucker and he's
killing it. They said it's killing it.
It's awesome. Yeah, the mission possible
yet me to hear and it's fantastic.
He's awesome. He's really star Fuck.
But he's awesome. He's awesome.
Nice. His Shit. You know what else,
dude? He's, he was watch this.
He jumps off this and breaks his
ankle and he really did that.
Did the watch when he lands,
watch how Jack does apple get.
Boom.
All fucked up.
You ain't ready for that be you
want to be a worldwide action here?
I can't do that. I'll look at that
one showed hits. Watch HUD heads.
I don't quite make it.
Snapper Rooney Jog Dick to the metal.
He still finishing. He's still, yes. Look,
he's still jumped over the toughest
still and seen homeboy lamb that concrete
into his dick bone and look how he pulled
off. He hobbled off when he got up.
That's why you have to have a stunt
man cause you're going to get,
you guys are hardcore man,
but he likes everything.
He does all the car driving stunts
does all that shit. I didn't know that.
I didn't know. Look up your tongue. I
have to look up shit as a free country.
He might have a, a dark wish for the
end of one of those words. Oh my God.
He might have a dark,
which I have.
I have friend people discredit them
because the Scientology stuff, absolutely.
100% do and Burlison the Scientology
thing is just how he gets by. Yup.
There's a lot of people that have
their own ideologies, but they,
believe it or not,
it might be radical left ideology.
There's a lot of conservative former
like actors that are like super
conservative. They're on Twitter, like
they're in it. They're in a cult, correct?
Correct. They're all rat. Everyone's
wrapped up in this own little thing.
His thing is just crazy. It's fucked by
a guy who was a science fiction author,
a war, a fucking captains coat on with
a bunch of turtles. He knew himself,
but they have some legit buildings.
You driven by the Hollywood actors.
They have legit actress, man.
Dude, Tom Cruise is fucking legit.
John Travolta has done
some silly nonsense,
but he's also Altimas also
done pulp fucking fashion.
He did carry when he was like really
back to the Saturday night live face off
dude. He's a very fit and active
as a terrible movie. Face off. Oh
one when they cut the face off
and put it on the other person,
naked structure magically changes.
And Nick Cage looks like John Travolta,
anti technology terrorist.
There's no way Bro. Okay.
What did it happen if Brian put it on you?
I would think
there's a Munster here. First
of all, your head's way bigger.
So your skin a bit like some
60 year old lady from Bel Air.
So 60 year old ladies where their mouth
looks like it's so big a key your head.
Cause they've been pulling,
they're pulling their skin back
to their mouth or like a joker.
They lose fat in their face.
As you get older, you, Meryl,
you used to make fun of me for taking an
acting class and I stayed in that last
for eight years longer than I needed
to because I love a train wreck.
And these two guys did a c Jeffrey tambor
was teaching and these two guys did a
scene from faceoff and
the curtain comes up and,
and one guy's hanging from a chain and
the other guy's torturing him and it's
like, and then he goes, yeah. And it's
all and he's hitting him and it's crazy.
And at the end of the scenes,
like scene, everybody was like,
and then Jeffrey tambor just takes
a sip of his coffee and he goes,
what was that scene? And the
guy goes, face off, face off.
What is that? It's a movie. It's an
action movie. John Travolta in an occasion
that's seen as band forever.
That was it. Moving man.
Yeah, whatever. God,
I heard this gaudy movie's terrible,
but it's like the worst movie of all time.
I've heard it already. Yeah. That was
like a zoo. Tomatoes. Well, I don't know.
I saw the, I saw the trailer and I got
into it. Okay, let's, let's just Google.
How bad is the Gotti movie?
It's, I mean, there was, it say
that's amazing. Two out
of 10 is insane. Okay,
that's great. That has to be
correct. He's great. He looks good.
It looks like a Bob. He looks good. He
looks like a good God. He John's fault.
Faultless.
Shulkin macked is Fox those j
Simpson on FX played a ship.
Oh, that's right. Yeah,
that's fine. These are credit.
He's a great actress and everything,
man. He just does a lot of bad movies.
You know shorty,
he just does not done a lot of bad movies.
I know Tom Cruise is
done from end of days.
Even like all those movies did he
know I love him. Guy was amazing.
It's fucking fantastic. Best movie.
You know what else is good with that?
What does the, is that the one the
tomorrow again he dies. It keeps dying.
That's it. Does that end of days?
No, I'm thinking of a different one.
He did like two science fiction movies.
I'm thinking of direct to tomorrow.
Yes. That was what it was called. It
was called edge it tomorrow originally.
And then like we've talked
about this before, the change.
That's right because the marketing,
cause it came out and kissed their
original marketing was edge of tomorrow,
whatever the fuck it came out.
And then people are like,
God that no one showed up to it.
But the people that went were like,
that's like the greatest movie ever.
So then it started to gain traction.
They're like, hold up, we
need to relabel this thing.
Then they relabeled it and that movie's
fucking, that might be his best movie.
It's a great fucking mood,
a great fucking science fiction movie.
It is one of the most underrated
science fiction movies ever.
And if you're a [inaudible] fan and
you avoided it just because, oh,
it's a Tom cruise movie. Yeah. You fucked
up because it is amazing. It's amazing.
I did a reading with him one time
and, and uh, he in the reading,
it was just literally me, him,
Eric Stoltz, Amy Smart Luby. Uh,
it was moving that never got made
called men and I, I was reading,
I was reading all the parts opposite
him and [inaudible] they were talking to
Owen Wilson. So I was right next
to him and I spent, I don't know,
maybe three hours with him and
it was a small, nobody was out.
Nobody else was in the room,
like just Todd Phillips and a couple bags.
He in the reading like in the
reading as you're just doing it,
acting full out and amazing and,
and just loves it.
And almost like his eyes were watery
at one point where everything's like,
all the chips are down in the scene.
And I was just like,
this fucking dude is up make.
I kept staring at him and I
believed everything he was
doing and just sitting at
a table and we get there, he's a
little late, just a little late,
profusely apologizes. He's got to,
haven't eaten. Just give me a second, I'm,
I've done about it. And he's
just talking. He's so nice.
And he had five pieces of Sashimi with
tiny little pepper on each one and some
Penta water. And he was like, thank you
so much. That was great. Pupil boom.
And then we went out red thing and then
he wanted to hear what all of us thought
of the script. What are suggestions
were? And when he listens to you,
his eyes sparkle, his mouth moves
in an oh like you can be like,
I think I was a little confused in the
beginning and he's like, Whoa, hold on.
What do you, what he, you know, he's
zeroed in on you. And I was like,
this guy loves me, man. We're going to be
best friends and then I never happened.
Yeah, we dated for it. We can put you
in the mission impossible or some shit.
I talk, I spent time with him.
Dude. You're not Scientology.
Well he could get you to join. I
think he could get you to join. Yeah.
I wouldn't show up and I'd be like,
yeah,
of course he would get mad
that you weren't showing up.
But if you did show up and you charmed
people there and just rub backs,
I know a lot of self taught
it that you loved them.
I was in the class for 10 years.
That is cited in the book by uh, in,
in um, going clear at that whole class
that, that I was in that class. She was,
I remember you had me come to one
of those little boots. Sure did.
I went to an event, a thing that was
going on, watch the guy saying we, we,
we watched the guys sing while we were
so high and we were in like a neighboring
dimension watching reality through a
dirty mirror in the Scientology building.
I want to get near there. It was
near there. It was that theater.
We were barbecued. I mean,
Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, Bubba,
Bubba, Bubba, bubba barbecue,
freaking out watching this that they were
singing musicals and it was not good.
And Joe was just like, wow,
this was amazing. So much money.
I drove by the one in, it's kind of like
the silver lake area, Hollywood man,
they've got a lot of money. Did you
read going clear this little book? It's,
there's, there's a lot of
what? What's good about crazy,
what's good about crazy
and about being like,
if you have a fucking purpose in life,
man, it doesn't have to be rational.
But if you have a purpose, if you have
like a clear directive in terms of,
you know,
l Ron Hubbard says this,
and so I'm just gonna listen and I'm going
to push forward and I'm going to stay
positive and I'm going to
avoid the negative people
and I'm gonna use all these
tools in order to maximize my performance.
All good shit works. Yeah. All good.
It could be to your thing, some
made up nonsense. And by the way,
if you read anything about, by the way,
when Callan's around and start saying,
by the way, by the way you read
anything about l Ron Hubbard,
they essentially think
that he was self healing,
that he was creating his bat shit crazy.
He was having you do an
inventory of how his brain works.
Like that's what he did.
He took it,
he took a detailed inventory
over many years of how, how uh,
how the minutia of his brain worked
and he really category he cataloged it.
That's why a lot of some
of it, he borrowed a lot of
like old systems and stuff.
But some of it is I love works.
I love you made everyone were
like navy fucking outfits.
Like the commanders were
like in AP fucking up.
But if you think about a Christianity c
focused the European and American mind
for a long time.
Yeah,
everybody was on the same page and it
was very easy to kind of move things
forward as a uniform body and nobody
kind of disputed what the truth was.
And so that's a reason that like with
Hubbard, I feel like with Scientology, um,
I'm pretty sure they're signups are
going down because of research and with
everyone in the sea org. That's
it. That's it. Oh my God.
Apparently that little design is cash to
the front. Yeah, it is. Whoop your ass.
You get on the line now. Yeah.
He's beat the shit. He made
the shit up. Yeah, right.
Yeah. Like if you're like, oh sorry sir,
your hands down just fucked up today.
Like beat your ass legitimately kick
people's ass. Apparently it was that.
Who was that said that David
Miscavige has dad. Is that his dad?
His Dad and then also on the document
you talked about how abusive and the book
is crazy. He goes into detail about
David Miscavige. Yeah, Tom Cruise.
Katie then I'm sorry, what
was his dad's name? Ron. Ron
Miscavige. Sorry, Ron. Hi Ron.
The podcast. Oh, interesting. Made me
sad. Yeah, it doesn't talk to his son.
You know that.
That's the thing that made me the most
sad that the dad and the son don't talk
to each other.
We over some nonsense.
The best thing I ever heard was a guy
I knew who was a teacher and he was had
Scientologists and had been for 23 years.
And somebody said,
are you a scientologist? And you kind
of get caught off guard. And he said,
well let's examine that for a sec.
I,
she's taking classes there for 20 years
and I've found enormous benefit from
some of them and some of them and I've
paid money for some of my found zero
benefit from. So, uh, and, and I, and
I put into practice some of the cuff,
you know, some of the courses and stuff.
So if that makes me a scientologist,
I guessed I am. It was kind of a good
answer. That's a very good answer. Yeah.
I mean that's, there's, you can get
that out of a lot of things. Sure.
There's a lot of things that are like
that, that have some nonsense in them,
but I think people operate really well
when they have like a scaffolding,
like a structure that they have to follow
it. Yeah. And then they have a purpose.
They think there's a Po,
a positive action,
their directive and that there's going
to be some grand plan that they fit.
Yeah, perfectly. Because of their work.
That's the wrong with that either.
Listen man, if that works for you, if you
push it until the contract breaks out,
but it's just if you bill. Yeah,
right. I mean look at Leah Remini.
I mean lear remedies.
She has the worst fucking person over.
This dude's
crazy man doesn't get off.
She doesn't give a fuck and cheese.
She likes being that girl.
That's her. She likes that role.
It's almost like she was
designed because he like,
it didn't make sense that she was in
Scientology to begin with when I met her.
Right. Because when I met, she's like
this take no bullshit. East Coast chick.
It was also beautiful. So I was
like, Huh, she's a scientologist.
I always got along with her always.
She was always very friendly,
but there was always this like be
careful don't same thing. Stupid jokes.
Like all right, Jesus. Yeah. I spelled
the same way. I had such a crush.
She had so much power.
So here's the thing,
if she's got all this machine
that she's just say by the bell,
but she's got all this like she's got
all this like brass and the weight,
how does she get sucked into
that? Well, she was a little kid.
That's how she grew up in it. She got
sold a bill of goods and so she was like,
wait a minute, boy. They
should have kept her.
But how did you Tom Cruise Tom.
How'd they get Tom Though? Like Tom wasn't
that young, was very young. He was very,
how they get them and John Travolta.
Well,
I think people want
something that makes it look,
I bought the book I bought
Diane. Yeah, me too.
I bought it through a late
night at 1994 son pre internet.
I was at home chilling in my apartment
in north Hollywood and I was like, damn,
this sounds like they're making a lot
of sense here and it doesn't make sense
the Laba,
but some of it does.
What are you 35 I'm 50 15
years older than you do.
You got to think. You don't really
remember before the Internet.
You were like an infant.
I was here as a grown man when the
Internet hit in 1994 but before that you
would get late night infomercials. You'd
be buying fucking squeegees and shit.
[inaudible] I was pre cell phone, bro.
Yeah. When I met him on the phone,
now I know you guys were older telling
you this is dianetics was something you'd
see on late night television and it was
really compelling because you can't do
any research. Dude. There was no Google.
There was no, there was no youtube.
Eddie Bravo would have been
his boss. Eddie knowledge. No,
but with all of us,
no one really knew.
This is how a lot of things snuck through.
This is,
you are curious all the way I
no, no, no, no, no. I never went.
We never thought,
we never thought that
Arnold Schwarzenegger or
[inaudible] or any of those
people were doing sterile shut the fuck
didn't I was seven and knew that before.
I knew they were doing stairs.
When I saw Rambo two I just thought that
was from weightlifting. No, I knew it.
Steroids when I was in high school.
I didn't think I didn't,
I didn't know that Hollywood, I didn't
know when you see demolition, man, I,
I just thought I was like, Dude,
how'd they get so fucking cut?
I've got to start working out.
I didn't know
that. Right, right. Maybe cause I
wasn't in the workout world, but I,
I mean I really, back then all
of us were naive to steroids.
We really weren't as, fuck.
Here's the thing is, man, we,
you could find out like, okay, what is
Scientology based on? You could find out,
you could find in, okay, does
chiropractic medicine work? Right?
You could Google stuff now and you could
look, okay, does fluoride cure cavities?
Right. We didn't get, we
didn't get an answer, but we
might be able to get a sense.
Sure. And you also get a sense of
like, here's the critics of Mercola,
this is what their perspective is.
Here's the critics of this natural
pathic site that might say some unfounded
things about vaccinations are
about. So there's always some, it's,
you can get a sense,
yes.
But you at least you
have a chance in 94 dude,
when I commend you didn't have a chance,
not a chance of Anthony Robbins cassettes.
I had a fucking PTO vinyl
thing and you open it up.
They have all these different cassettes
and I would listen to those by the pool
in my shitty apartment and rotating
around. Didn't you get a lot from,
I've got a lot. He's leaches. Fuck, I
got a lot of shit like Tony Robbins.
Tony Robbins is a bunch of people,
just a lot of shots.
Tony Robbins knows how the human
brain works. I found him in normal.
But there's guys that,
it's the same thing as like with musicians
or with carpenters or with comedians
and there's people that are just kind
of bumbling through it and this people
that kill it when it comes to like the
self help, personal growth type shit,
he kills it. Here's what's interesting.
People are so goofy that you know,
he does those cold walk things.
These dumb motherfuckers are trying to
take selfies while they're coal walk and
they're burning their feet off cause
he's stupid fucks actually believe that
they're the, the power of their will is
keeping them from this is how it works.
You Idiots. Okay. Kohl's. This is an, I
only found this out a couple of days ago.
Coles are not very good
at projecting heat.
That's why you put a
fucking frying pan down.
You put it that's a conductor
of heat and want that metal.
The metal's going to cook well, things
don't cook that good on Kohl's. Yeah,
it's not the same.
It's weight like got really hot.
Pan will fuck you up way quicker
than Coles so you can run on coals.
If you move quick, you just
got to go quick at the end
you'd be like, ah, Ooh, ah,
but you can actually do it.
If you have some calluses on
your feet and move quick enough,
you won't get burned. So, but
these dummies didn't even move.
They just served their fixtures.
Pictures on fucking coals.
I've just got the power of now
because she's doing it for them.
That's so inconvenient because
you can't walk anywhere.
You know Shane Mouse,
the standup comic? No,
he was hiking at night and jumped off of
like a cliff and landed on his feet and
broke both of his feet fucking a,
he jumped and landed like 10
feet below in the mountains.
He had to figure out how to get down here.
He was just fucked up.
He made a mistake. I forget the exact
story. Do you remember the exact story?
It was like a very like normal jump.
It wasn't anything crazy like
he didn't jump somewhere.
He just like dropped her
like, oh, we took a step down.
I might be conflating him with someone
else who was another person I know that
fell at night and they did.
They might be a different story.
I'm thinking of a second guy
also fell on cliffs. Either way.
Shane mouse broke both of his feet.
I think he was on crutches for six months,
I think. And I think it was the book
blood Meridian. And he talks about,
and this apparently was a
practice and as there was a tribe,
this cowboy gets captured by these native
Americans and native Americans killed
his whole posse. And then they take
him and they take his feet, uh,
his shoes off and they just cut
the first layer of his feet off.
They kind of give a nice shaving.
So like just the soles of his
feet are taken off and they,
and so he would have to crawl back into
towns to explain to them who the fuck
was out there.
We had to crawl like 10 miles and shit.
Oh my God. Yeah. He says, I said, I
landed a new, I broke both my heels.
My left foot was in really bad shape.
The right foot wasn't bad.
I could still use my right toes.
So with the help of my friend who had
the hike around the other way after we
decided to jump,
may not be the best idea.
I had to spend the next two hours scooting
down the mountain on my butt hands
and right toes until we got to a flat
enough surface where he and some strangers
carry me to his car.
He and his wife then had to go a couple
of hospitals until we found an er that
was not too busy to see me. God, Whoa.
Part is, you know, it was my birthday.
Quick hike, have some Sushi, catch
a movie. Pretty low. Key night.
He looked at this shortcut. I'd want
to try and involve jumping off a cliff.
That was about 11 feet.
I was wearing some barefoot running shoes
that were not appropriate for landing
and I thought it would
be too high of a jump.
We looked into for a few minutes and
talked about it and then we decided to go
for it because we were dumb
guys and that's the sort
of thing that dumb guys do,
not this.
So he jumped 11 feet onto fucking
rock in barefoot shoes and smashed.
Here's my question. You're so
crazy to do. Here's my question.
Before cautious Dasia for
anesthesia and x rays.
When you did that go to it.
Well you got back to town even.
What would they do?
Go in to just set your ankle cause
that's a, that's not a complicated joint.
He'll fuck. Fuck right.
So fun just to cripple.
Thinking about how tall 11 feet is.
Then jumping from that
down to rocks with dude,
I don't even like running in those
barefoot. She's hard on your feet. I do.
I run on them but I got to be careful
like where I step. I have to be careful.
Like you got to look what you can't step
on a jagged rock cause it goes right
now. Whereas if you're wearing
something like these, these are,
these are trail running shoes.
I run these,
I can step on anything
with these fucking things.
So I alternate when I trail run.
I alternate with shoes like this that I
could just run anything and then those
vibrams or the vivo barefoot ones. But
you gotta be careful with those things.
Fuck jumping from 11 feet, that
basketball, I left 10 feet,
another foot above that is crazy. And
under rocks. That's what guys do is crazy.
That is such a dumb thing to do.
Breaking your feet or your ankles
or your legs or break your elbow.
You like shit broke. My elbow is still
good though. You're going to be all right.
Yeah,
you're going to be all right.
But you can get a blister apparently in
the wrong place when you're hiking away
up to the mountains and it can kill you.
John can par got a blister on his
foot or a in his, the head is,
he'll crapped. Got It
infected. He was in Thailand,
it infected and he missed his daughter's
fight and had to stay at a hospital in
Thailand and get ivy antibiotics.
It must have been so bad.
Cause John's at night,
he's a fucking animal and his daughter's
fighting and Thailand. I mean, you know,
and he basically,
he started his whole career in Thailand,
practically. Dude, crazy.
Its foot was all swollen up like you
gotta be careful with your feet, man.
Oh yeah, yeah. We'll chop off.
Cliffs had an ingrown toenail.
My brothers were so bad when we, when
he was in high school, I went with him.
Here's who kept just, they kept growing
into it. They had to take needles,
numb his fucking underneath this
toenail and then Jank his toenails owl.
That's a trap. And then since the
tops of the toenail doesn't grow back,
so it just looks like the bottom of your
foot looks like the bottom of your feet
a second now as no nails. Oh
my God. What, what but, but,
but that was because they were in Groner
there was no, he's born like that.
They kept growing. It kept growing
in and so he has no nails now.
No nails they took in Sinja it's very
creepy cause cause soft shit though.
Feels like Qualis knows,
Whoa,
my dad's got some nails
and under those nails,
toe j spot seven, eight years
of fungus, toe jam and Earl,
well let's just some thick now.
So he's got nails.
I mean it about a stick is the
lid of this table right here.
Roll dudes toes and their ass.
She has healed that are all cracked.
It's nice. 14 show too by the way.
Cause his head, his foot is
that, it does, it's got a pace.
So I opened up for Brian in Chicago and
I do like this dirty pit put in the back
and his, his mom and
his dad. I'm like, oh,
it hit me right when they walked into it.
Oh fuck.
I just did that in front of Brian's
mom, dad, his two kids and his wife.
I was like, notice I just went quiet.
I was so, I was like, oh great.
That was funny though. He got to do what
you gotta do. That's what I was like.
You guys decide, hey, you decided to
come. Yeah, he got to do my thing.
I apologize and loved it. I was
so embarrassed. That's common.
You don't get mad talk now. Don't
get mad. That's great. Great shows.
Your Dad doesn't shout out to Chicago.
Thought Thalia Hall.
Thanks everybody for coming
out. Sold out three shows. Yes.
So when you do this now is
this a self funded thing?
This is a comedy dynamics.
Uh,
so they're doing a lot of specialists and
they did a great job. I love the space.
It looked how many different specialties
that they done. Who's, uh, who's the 170.
That is incredible. That's incredible.
Yeah. They might be the most ever. Yes.
Who's done more? I don't think anybody
that's incredibly invoke Weiss.
He's great and, and uh, but they
did such a good job and I, I'm,
I captured everything on one to,
so I'm pumped.
I think it's best thing I've ever
done. That's beautiful. Yeah.
Chicago is a great fucking talented,
great guy. Love she play too.
I wasn't a fan too.
We did this,
such a history of violence where
Improv was invented. I mean,
it's just a great town too. It's like,
it's got a lot of different qualities.
It's got a bit of Midwest politeness
and it's got a big city mentality. Yep.
All together. It's a weird
spot. Yeah, it's weird.
It's a weird spot because it's like
a little bit of both great food,
friendliest people. People not
afraid to get fat. That is correct.
So not afraid. Carbon
up, carb central. I mean,
they looked at pizza when they went.
This is not unhealthy enough
dishes at about six inches.
We had no fucking Pete's
out there, Brian. Oh my God.
Chicago's now America's rat capitol.
Chicago beats out in New York City,
Boston and Washington DC as
America's rat capital. Okay,
here's the problem with this problem.
They don't know how many rats are
out there. They're just bullshitting.
I'm not doing a detailed fucking
analysis and know where they live. Yeah.
Well how do you know how many,
how do they really know how
many rats there are in New York?
Cause they just guessing.
I don't think so.
I think they can actually don't
they can't. They tell by like,
like my buddy had Allianz. What's
that? There's off of complaints.
I'll get it though. Fuck Daddy, look
at it again. Chicago's complaining more
Chicago known for being
in Boston.
I'd be scared of a fucking road. Come on
Bro. Who am I going to call about a rat?
That's why La is not other than
one kilo. My, my buddy had a,
bought a building in New York and he
had to clean it out in the basement.
Jimmy Burke told me,
my buddy Steve Shakur was coming out when
they were killing them. They had this,
they were poisoning them.
They were coming out with garbage bags,
the industrial size, garbage bags full
of rats. And they did it for two days.
It was thousands, tens of
thousands million rats, some shit.
That documentary on Netflix.
Netflix is insane and amazing.
It is clean rat though. I
like man, Cutie Pie. Yeah,
look cute that someone's got like as a
pet until they carry the bubonic plague.
I like the white ones with red eyes.
So they decided that that's not true.
I think they decided that it was
actually a fleas that were on the rats,
that character. It was the fleet, the
fleet. So you can't really blame the rats.
The rats carried the fleas, but that's
like we carried the bubonic plague.
We going to blame humans for the plague.
Yes.
We always look to like swine flu,
Bro.
K from the pigs has giant rat bigger
than a dog near the playground.
Nutria. That's master splintered. No,
it's a different kind of animal
to nutrients from West towns.
It's still a giant fucking version of
a Aramco. They have a lot of those,
you know, they're starting to see those
in Texas now in different, uh, they're,
they're spreading across the
lower part of this country.
Can you make him pet kind of cool?
They bet pears are good.
Eat and they're like a beaver. Yes. Yes.
David [inaudible] had an
episode of his TV show.
I remember that TV show that you would
do. Yes. They went nutria hunting.
Yeah. And everywhere. I think it was
in Louisiana, I don't quite know. Got
talking about one of those motherfuckers
take hold. Once they're there,
it's real difficult to shake them off.
Rinella actually had an episode of his
podcast of about a place where they were
killing all the killing off the nutria
and how they figured out how to do it.
Yeah. It's a crazy thing. That little
animal. So I brought it over here.
Did you see crazy animals? I saw
your Instagram joke. How were,
how were the craziest animals in Thailand?
You know what the most depressing
thing was? We went to one of those, uh,
tiger sanctuary things like
drug the fuck up for sure.
Do you know why? How you can tell because
people get in there. Well first of all,
because the the babies,
they'll let you touch the baby's first.
There's like different packages you could
package the baby package or the young
lion package or the giant line,
get that VIP package. I'll take,
I'll take the babies are adorable,
these little cute things,
but they're super like playful and
active and big and then you get to like a
little bigger and they seem to be
behaving normal and they have a bunch of
trainers in there with them.
And then you get to the big ones and the
big ones are fucking doped out of their
mind. Like they just gave
him a bucket of heroin.
So they're just laying there like this,
like looking at you. I believe it, dude,
they didn't,
none of them got up.
They just laid there and people lay next
to him and hug him and take pictures
with God. Damn Dude. But it's
weird. Kids and wife do that. No,
fuck that. I'm the lines like, oh fuck,
I feel better. Well the woman got,
we were there. We didn't know
what it was until we got there.
I got super depressed like immediately,
but when we were there the the,
the oldest we got to is like a nine
month cat and that cat does not seem like
it's drugged up at all. How they're young,
they're pretty big man. Like a mastiff.
It'll fuck you up. Still fucked.
Well their Chai and cat still.
Oh a hundred percent fuck you up dude.
But it's like a seven month, eight month,
nine month cat in there. Like big
like a dog. The big dog. Yeah,
she got try that shit. You ever see
a massive at six months it's pretty,
pretty bad. Yeah. Six months. Yeah. Cats
bigger. So this thing is bigger than that,
you know, probably 175
pounds, something like that.
200 pounds and it's just hanging around
and they have all these trainers that
are just like around the cat all the time.
We're like,
what in the fuck are we doing?
Like you know what? Fuck this.
Well they have guns and stuff.
They have like sticks with them.
They keep the kid that cats are
listening to them for the most part,
but then it gets to an untenable
size. Yeah. And they're also, yeah,
and they have these things in these
cages and then there was other ones that
clearly weren't drugged up.
Like he pass by one cage and this one's
less walking back and forth and pacing
and looking at you and looking
at everybody. I'm like,
okay, he's awake. He's legit.
He just got off his meds.
Yeah.
And these other ones are
just dragged down like this.
It is a drag wife bummed out
to everybody was bummed out.
Everybody was pumped out. It's a
drag man. That's a big found one.
That was a selling tiger parts.
Sure man.
People are poor. They're taking risks
ladder and shit. Not Good. The other,
the bear gallbladders apparently such
an issue that like some Asian countries
want bare gallbladder. Uh,
some people like it. It's
like some sort of a delicacy.
It's supposed to have some
weird properties to it.
Probably like probably like
Rhino Horn type properties.
But it's so bad that in British
Columbia, if you hunt bear, I say,
if you want a black bear, you're not
allowed to open up the body cavity. Okay.
You have to take the meat off the outside.
You can't even go into the
body cavity. Wow. Yeah.
They have a law against it because
they don't want people harvesting bear
gallbladders back and they don't
want people killing them. Yes.
Bear Bile does have additional uses,
but there are cruelty free alternatives.
Bear bile has been used in traditional
Asian medicine for thousands of years,
contains high levels of
good luck. This word, Urso,
deoxycholic acid known to be useful
for treating liver and gallbladder
conditions, so it does have
some medicinal value to tail,
but I had friends that were bear hunting
and people were asking them for the
gallbladders and they were like, it's
illegal. He's like, God, just get it.
Get it from my grandma. You know,
she really likes it. You know, like,
get the fuck Outta here, man. That's
like, it's a bad thing to have,
but I'll give you get caught with it.
It's like you're getting caught
with something you're not,
it's not legal to possess a
part of an animal that you're,
it's legal to for you to kill it.
And that's what's crazy.
Stop and think about that. Yeah, you
can kill it. You can kill the animal.
You just can't possess a part of its
body. Yeah. You're not allowed to get,
you're not allowed to open his calf.
Not that I know.
It goes to waste.
You could use it,
but you can't use it because
so many people want it that
they made it illegal to
have it. Wow. Because bile is
always been used. Apparently.
I said one of the compounds or whoever
it is. That's good. Birth control.
It's your mouth. Oh, be want to. No,
but it's used for like medicine, you know,
some medicines like anti disinfectant.
Yeah. Bio was always a traditional
medicine that actually worked.
I mean if you mixed it with
the hose down there though,
I love that was way different.
The elephant was a really positive
experience because the elephants are in a
Rehab Center where they actually intrude,
reintroduce them back to the wild.
And we see the way these people, first
of all, they're not contained. They roam.
Yeah. Not only do they roam,
they, they, there's no fence.
They let people in when the florist
bro, they come out of the forest. Yeah.
The people are all there with them,
like moving care of them, feeding them.
They're constantly giving them sugar
cane, washing them, cleaning them.
And when you're there, like
they, they document their,
they're trying to explain how all the
money that you pay for to experience
hanging out with these elephants
for a day goes to rehabilitation.
And we talked about all the different,
it goes to food and they've reintroduced
seven elephants into the wild through
this one facility, which is giant. It's
a live wild. So they're in Thailand? Yes.
There's a lot of elephants. And so
while the, where these people are, the,
the forest is like super dense man and
the elephants just wander through the
forest eating whatever the fuck they
want it is. It's crazy to see men.
So the kind of wild, they're wild.
They're wild, but they're not,
a lot of them came from zoos. A lot of
them came from circuses, but they can be,
they look, they're basically
living like they would in the wild,
so it's not a giant stretch to take them
and reintroduce them to a place as long
as there's food there. Fairly tame.
The wild. They just traded big dude.
They do whatever the fuck they want
and grab them. They're fucking trunks.
Are they soft? No. It's hard as a rock.
There's 600 muscles in their
trunk alone and no bones,
600 muscles just in the trunk.
Just so physical strength is so
insane. Dude. It's so hard when you,
when you were around them
and you realize like, Oh God,
like you shouldn't I the
riding and was sketchy.
Like it's sketchy because you
worry. Well good. If they fall,
like one of them slipped a little bit
con itself and one lady did fall off and
she was okay,
but it's,
it's a possibility that you could
fall off of the fucking elephant,
which you are. You're 10 feet up. Yeah.
I mean these are just some of them.
This one lady had a, I had a female
that I was riding this one lady,
and you're only riding it for like you
in a basket weaving a basket or just on
it and you just on it
really holding onto a rope.
They put a rope around the waist
and you hold onto the rope.
It's like loosely around
that. You've barely on man.
Yeah, you're barely on. Wow.
You know, they just, and if they
wanted you off, you're off instantly.
You weigh nothing to them
or feels like on my back,
itches came over to what I had was,
and the one this lady had next to me
was literally 30% 40% larger than hers.
It was so big and it was a male. And when
it trumpets, when it just decided, okay,
like right next to everybody.
Everybody wanted more stuff so loud.
You just realize what it is. I think
it was, it was raining every day.
It rains constantly.
This is a rainy season two
and this elephant is moving
through the mist and the
forest and just eating whatever it
wants or these giant white tusks.
And I'm like,
that is a crazy living being.
That's a crazy majestic animal.
Have you seen them?
It was dope.
Have you seen the video where it,
where there's a bull elephant hitting
I'd Mack truck. Oh yeah. Just,
oh it trucks it over.
Cause they've added a bunch of them in
India where they get tired of being a
boot abused and they just go nuts.
But with this thing that
these animals were loved,
like you could really tell like first
of all you forced them with your hands.
You know that when we give them
sugar cane, you're so scared.
Cause his mouth is giant.
But you put it in there and
they're just super gentleman.
They don't snap out of nothing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's soft.
I mean it's,
it's not like it's like a bowling,
but the trunk is insanely powerful.
They just grab shit with that thing
and rip it out of the room. Cool.
Animals snap things like blogs and shit
with their trunks and they walk and feel
like what humans feel like when one
dies, they mourn shit of it. Yeah. Well,
they definitely have incredible memories
because there was one video of an
elephant meeting and elephant that had
been separated from for 20 years and they
met each other and they run to each
other and they're bouncing around. Yeah,
they recognize each other.
I like this really calm,
weird animal that eats everything.
Dude.
You realize like one of
the things I was thinking,
I was like imagine if you had one
of these that lived in your yard.
You had to have no yard. No. This is the
problem that people have in Africa. Kay.
I'm a giant fan of elephants.
But if you're a poor farmer and
you live in this prior crop, yeah,
just come right through your cross.
You can't do anything about it.
You're starving.
You have children.
Imagine you have your little boy and
your little boy is going to go hungry now
cause he's elephants just
want to eat whatever the fuck.
They don't understand that you
can grow this elephant. Huh?
Well elephant is the argument
for controlling some of the pop.
See Cause we always think we say,
oh elephants are endangered.
Well they definitely are. Then
some places, but in other places,
in certain areas to call
large populations, you got
to realize how big Africa is.
I mean, if you ever see like
the map or they take America,
they put it inside of Africa and they'd
put Asian side of Africa. Now let me see,
I have not seen that. Oh
my God, Africa's giant.
[inaudible] do we have to kill them?
Can't we redirect these fuckers?
So a lot of money to do. That's the
problem. The real problem is the money.
Cause you,
you could maybe could grab them and
capture them and move them fucking hell.
Yeah. Maybe that's how they do it.
And they put them in a zoo. I mean,
there has to be some capital,
very short distance with
that tranquilizer higher.
So big cloth underneath. And now
looking back at that, look how big our,
that's not true. Yes it is. Is broke.
Africa. Africa is so big, dude.
Is that true? Yep. It has all of China
in it. All of the United States. Yup.
Yup. Come of India. I'm
amazing that all of Japan,
all Spain too. That's not
to dude. All of Italy.
Dude, why does it have Japan? It
didn't make the high Japan's over. No,
I made it up. Japan is the
bottle, so that's real. That's,
that's insane man.
That's so big. So, okay.
So imagine United States.
Imagine if we are over here in,
uh, California and we're
like, Ooh, I don't see any
fucking elephants. Meanwhile,
in New York, they're just getting trampled
through Manhattan. Elif and we're like,
don't kill the orphans, Bro. They're
nowhere to look. Well, Calabasas,
you don't see a single fucking elephant
man. Don't be an asshole. Meanwhile,
your grantees getting
stomped. It does, it works
because there's very little continuous
habitat for the migrations apparently.
Well, yeah, I think there's a lot
of problems with, with, you know,
the places where they're underpopulated
the places where they're overpopulated.
It's just, it's, you know, it's just
a, it's a crazy, amazing animal.
It would be really nice if people could
figure out a way to live in peace with
OE exists. It is. They were saying any
animal to be around. They were saying how,
uh, I was watching this on
animal plant or some shit,
but you know how they take out the bull
elephants and people are cool with it
cause you know they killed the smaller
ones are they fucked things up.
They're saying the problem with that with
elephants is those older ones know the
path to water and where to go.
And when you kill the older ones,
the other ones don't know
where the files go teach.
The younger ones had behaved so,
so they watched their like pass.
Once you take out the bull and they're,
they're fun because they're saying the
older ones have so much knowledge to drop
on these little bastards.
We have certain animals that we get
super mad if someone kills an elephant is
one of them. And a giraffe was another one
fuck yet, because they're not, you know,
they're not,
they're not predators.
You know what I read about that giraffe
that that lady killed and she got in
trouble. Here's the one. It was
a giant old 18 year old giraffe.
It was killing young males,
killed three young males.
They were going to have to kill it anyway.
Yeah.
So that's how they get a person
like that to do it. You know,
the only other option is they could take
it and put it in some sort of a zoo,
but it was a non-viable mail. And when
non-viable males around young males,
apparently they kill him. They
all sit. Don't mention that,
that that revenue she paid, you pay a
lot of money to kill the $50,000. A lot.
That revenue goes back
into the community there.
And I guess there's no such thing
as a black giraffe and was like,
that's a black dress. Like No. Well
when they get old they get darker. Yeah.
But it's really rare that an animal
in the wild gets to 18 years old.
Fucking big. Huge. But again,
when you kill off that big,
mainly a lot of knowledge to drop
on these other little [inaudible],
he wasn't dropping any
knowledge. She's killing us.
See, they're different. That it,
that's the reason why that Cory
Knowlton, I think that was his name. Um,
he got in trouble for shooting that
rhino a pay $250,000 to shoot a rhino.
It was,
it was,
they were going to have to kill it because
it did killed a male and it killed a
female kill the male breeding her and
it killed a young, uh, no killed him,
a female breeding her and it killed
the young man and he was so old.
He paid I think $391,000 or
something crazy like that.
Is he just scrooge McDuck rich, he wants
to kill the oils family. He's balling.
And you wanted to kill the rhinos, that
pad. Is that his name to hunter? Yeah,
I talked to him. We had it on the
podcast. Really Smart Guy. But not,
not what you think when you
think of a guy who, you know,
does something like that,
but his nature not going to take care
of itself with these rails. Now they're,
they're so endangered cause the rhinos
or the rhinos are so endangered that it's
very dangerous to just let nature
take its course out because nature,
the animals have gone extinct. You
know, if you really go over the,
the list of animals that have been
extinct just by will, we've been alive.
You don't think about
it. But there's been a lot. And then if
you look over the course of human history,
fuck man,
a lot of animals have gone extinct.
Should have not living in a natural
habitat anyway. Then their, their,
their habitat has been so fucked with,
to begin with of us.
And there's so few aisles back in the day,
yes,
the nature would have found its way.
But when you have the thing,
is this guys 300 grand or whatever it
is that's going to go directly into
keeping those other ones a lie.
I think I have plenty for the scientists.
They're going to have money for it.
He'll type poaching efforts. It's just,
it seems counterintuitive.
I know.
It seems you're natural instinct when
they post it on the gram, like, oh,
just fucking killed this black
drafts. Like God damn bitch. Right.
And why would you,
why would you want to shoot a giraffe?
Why would you want to shoot a rhino? I
kid, I get it, man. It's, uh, but it's,
it's more complicated than you think it
is. Yeah. You know what I'm suspect of?
You know, there's poachers that
were killed by those lions. Yeah.
I don't think that happened. I think
they got shot. Your conspiracy guys,
I think they got shot by
poachers and the posters,
like it's a lot easier just to say
that they got eaten by lions out.
I will tell you as a fact,
I know people that have gone over there
to hunt and they just shoot at poachers.
Just shoot at them. Yeah. And
obviously we're talking about Africa.
So now you normous enormous place.
So I mean,
it might not feel like they're starting
hunters and gatherers and kill poachers.
It's entirely possible that that happens.
So hunting,
but I'm saying that the people that are
the professionals that work on those
giant ranches, like there's a lot
of these private hunting ranches,
they're like hundreds of
thousands of acres even in,
they're all fenced in and
people get inside and they
poach. What does that mean?
That means they're trying to eat right.
You know, it means they're starving.
And a lot of times,
and they're trying to do whatever
the fuck they can to make money.
Whether they can make money by chopping
off a rhino horn where they make money
by selling meat from some
antelope that they shot.
They weren't supposed to
shoot, but my, what I,
my point is that people have told me
that they know of these people over there
shooting at poachers, just shooting
at them like you would shoot at a,
a rat or a coyote or something that was
trying to eat your chickens or something.
Of course you shoot him the lines
and come along. We might be right.
It feels like my friend,
my friend who was over there
said he couldn't believe it,
that they just will shoot at poachers.
Danielle was shooting youtube.
I was gonna say pictures. No, that's
right. They're also part of it.
Some of them are organized gangs and man,
you know,
it's one of those things were like,
what would you do if you
were in that village?
You'd be in that fucking organized
gang to price stay out of Africa. Well,
if you're born there, but I'm saying
us. Oh well how about malaria?
Which has killed half of the
people that have ever died ever.
You have to get all those shots go.
My wife's doing that right now.
She's going to Kenya first
class, first class safari.
I can't make it. I've got
to go to China, Beijing,
there's no matter which one's worse.
Yo, here's the thing about China.
We had a stop in, in China, they have
different sense of personal space.
Like as far as like getting in between
you and align. They don't give a fuck.
You walking through a thing and
then just like a merging thing.
There's no merging sign. They're going to
go right into the kids. Right into you,
your wife. They drive like
that. But they're not,
they're not rude.
It's just a different way.
Cause there's so many people have to
figure it out. Exactly. Here's a billing.
They're not,
they're not impolite people,
but they get misconstrued as being
impolite cause we're not used to that.
Navigating that kind of numbers like
they are. It's crazy to see though, man.
Watch them. Even if you're just
watching them do it with other people,
just walk right in front of people and
smash into each other. If you do that,
you'd be like, fuck man, get mad at you.
When I went to Australia, a lot of, uh,
Chinese and Japanese and Koreans were
on holiday in Australia and I was with
Chin. Who's Korean? My producer, and
they've kept their super, we'd be in line,
they'd bump into someone. I'm
like, dude, what the fuck?
And he's like, no, no, no, no.
They're not being disrespectful. It's
literally just how, that's how they,
that's how they grew up. They just got
stood out. Stupid numbers of people. We,
you get used to people bumping into
each other a little bit about your way.
There's none of them. India is kind
of similar, leaving stack behind you.
Really close to them. This is the
art. I mean this is the trend, right?
The argument is that you get too many
people and then the people lose their
value because they become a hindrance.
Like I was thinking that yesterday.
I was at the four oh five, it's six
o'clock yesterday. Oh, you've been there.
It is a crazy thing to experience because
I was looking to get into it after
this.
But yeah,
it also makes you think like if there
was an end of the world type scenario and
you were trying to get back to your
family, right, you got zero chance.
You gotta you're gonna, you're gonna walk
way quicker. The 20 miles of your house.
You want to get a helicopter,
bro. Bilberry has one.
He flies on around, but he doesn't
have his own. He took lessons.
Bill knows how to fly bills on a
helicopter. He flies all the time. Right?
All the time. He flew down to San
Diego for a Gig and flew back.
Really cool. Yeah. It's funny.
I flew from San Diego to La.
Don't ask me how and why, but it,
my plan had a stop over in San
Diego, 26 minutes. That's hilarious.
That's a hilarious flight. Six
hours we'll be, we'll be unfair.
So you get that traffic, it's six hours.
You've got to plan that motherfucker.
Correct. Because at the comedy store
at La Jolla, the Thursday night show,
eight o'clock I was like, oh dude, if
I leave by two we got this all day.
I got there right at eight right?
It took you six hours.
There's accidents off. Oh my
God. Then I had to take, right.
When you get into San Diego,
orange county,
Orange County has so many people
and it's like a little China.
It's gorgeous though. It's so key.
It's beautiful, but it's so crazy.
You go there and like just the density
of people in Orange. Kind of like,
wait a minute, how many people
are here? This is a crazy spot,
but then there's some dope spots
like learning the Gal. Oh yeah.
I like to come to Chicago to go 11
miles took us an hour and a half ago.
We're traffic. Ever.
See my left? No, dude,
it can't be worse than going through
Orange County at five o'clock it's no
fucking bad. I asked the Uber. It
does. I said, is it always like this?
And they said it's like this because
of the construction right now in 2015,
three point 17 million
people just in Orange County.
And that does not include Mexicans.
It's just does not,
they don't know. They don't have a
fucking clue. And when I say Mexicans,
I should say, he people will let you
in. You're here. All right. That's,
that's what they should say.
Hey, you're here. You get in.
But the point is all these, uh, these
numbers are inflated. Like how many,
how many more illegal aliens
are here on top of that night.
But I live in Orange County.
If I didn't have to work in La,
I'd live in Orange County. What do you
mean? I would, I would live there all day.
I would live there. All loved Newport
best. What do you think the numbers are?
How many people, how many illegal aliens
do you think are in Orange County?
I was 3.1 7 million people.
How many people do you think
are illegal aliens? 67 million.
Like I feel like it's
one of those numbers,
like if they're documented or
undocumented, like how are you guessing?
It fluctuates. Probably. I don't want
to compare them to the rat study.
So disrespectful thing. I'm just
mean in terms of a study. Do we go,
you're not actually monitoring, like
how do you, how the fuck do you know?
We know how many they think or they
estimate sneak across every year. Yes.
Good question. I think they do. Do we have
any idea Jamie? Because then we could,
I have no fucking clue.
You imagine if you were living in some
shit country and you realize that you
could actually get a great job if
you could just get across the river.
It's such a bummer. Yeah. What's so
heartbreaking? What a shit we got to,
but meanwhile there's some
sweet spots down there like,
why don't we gentrify Mexico? Well, that's
the thing. Mexico City's getting there.
Yeah.
Mexico City's economy's doing a Pr
Mexico's economy is doing pretty well from
what I hear this, you got
Nicaragua, El Salvador, this is,
this is in 2014 so triple it.
It's two thousand two million three
hundred fifty thousand just in southern
California. Look at Delaware
just alone. Yeah, I know,
but that's the entire state of California.
That's off by a factor of 10 by
2.3 million to Orange County. Yeah.
There's no way they know.
They don't know mad if they need,
they ship a lot of the economy though.
They make up 11 million total of our
agricultural economy and everything else.
Man. We need those right
now. They're in trench.
It's heartbreaking when they have to
pass the rivers in the body of water and
it's like kids and women, they
die in the fucking heartbreaking.
Yeah, I mean it, and they got
to put together, you know,
the average is $3,000 $3,000 to them.
They come from nothing.
So they save all this money.
It's per person. So you got kids,
yet the family get together, they
get robbed, they go, they get robbed.
All their shit. It's, some of it's fake.
They don't know who to deal with. Well,
I'm sure you've seen videos of
Syrian refugees washing up on shore.
I can't handle it. It's hard. You
got to, you know, and it's so easy,
such a trash.
It's so easy to to
like look at them and they
speak a different language.
They follow different religion.
It's so easy to not [inaudible]
not for you.
You're a compassionate person.
So cosmopolitan to Syrians were not
religious searings where entrepreneurs,
I mean it, Damascus was a huge city.
I mean it's beautiful place. Very,
very cosmopolitan.
Basically European.
Not to let them in because we're scared
that you know the tears, stuff like that.
That's like not letting the
talent talented because the mafia,
it's gets such us in
a way fucking percent.
It's not necessarily but not the scene.
All I'm saying though like that to assume
that all Mexicans are in the cartel or
all, all Italians are in the mafia.
It's fucking insane. It's a similar,
it's a similar thing,
but it's especially like the thing,
the difference between Syrians
and Mexicans is Mexicans.
A lot of people would accept
them easier because they,
they practice the same religion.
Like if you found a guy who was a
Mexican businessman in Mexico City and he
speaks English and Spanish and his
children are well educated and you want to
move next door to you, we're more familiar
with Santa Monica, you'd be pumped.
Like he's a good guy. Yeah. He came
over from Mexico. Super Nice Guy.
Makes his own wine, you know, you know
what I mean? But, but if a guy does,
Mexican food is part of
the American fabric hundred
percent you know what I mean?
So we were not as threatened. They're
our neighbors. There's a history.
What are you threatened?
We'll people are threatened by Muslims
were threatened with, well they're,
they're threatened by a radical Islamic
terrorist are threatened by the idea of
people trying to be like some Manchurian
candidate and get into office.
A lot of these schools,
the school shoe with the mass shooters,
a lot of them are white too.
Man. We're scared of the,
most of them are white going.
Well do you remember when people
were absolutely convinced that, uh,
Obama was somehow some sort of
a Mexican plant, or excuse me,
Islamic plan and that he was a Manchurian
candidate and you can't get into
office. Trump said he was from
Kenya. That was, Trump was a birther,
people forgot about that. He had to
show his brush wanting to play him.
But he might have actually believed that.
But it also might've been that Trump like
fucking with Obama because Obama like
fucking with Trump.
True.
And that's one of the things I get that
press corpse dinner where he got up and
said,
here's one thing that I am that you'll
never be as president of United States.
And he got this giant laugh like
Seth Meyers roasted him too.
He's like, Oh really? Oh that's
cute. That's cute. Guess what?
Just why be the fucking president?
But he that,
so when he said something about Obama,
it more than likely it was because of
a personal feud and less likely that he
actually thought Obama was from Kenya.
He was probably fucking with him back
100%. Yeah, because he's a powerful guy.
And if they treat him like he's
not a powerful guy, he's like, oh,
read his resources to so he's like,
what this,
this is my problem with anti-Trump.
Like when,
when when people go too far with it,
it's not that he's not
doing terrible things.
It's not that he's not like just
the idea that he lies all the time,
that you have to check them on his lies.
You have to figure out what's the truth,
what's, it's a very dangerous
but separating the immigrant.
My issue has nothing to do with that.
My issue has to do with,
it's a terrible way to interact with
someone whose ideas you don't like because
it just makes the people that
support him more aggressive.
Everybody gets more aggressive. You get
more aggressive at them and you'll like,
this is what we're going to do.
We're going to shout him down.
We're going to stop
them off from speaking.
We're going to who we're going to show
up at their their restaurants and yell at
them. You're just creating
more conflict. This is helping.
This is not helping because they're
going to bolster their resource and not
persuading and build up their defenses.
No,
you're not Asian people and you're
going to make people arm themselves and
you're going to make people escalate
their rhetoric and it's going to escalate
on both sides.
And it's also evidence that
you're unhinged so they
can point to the fact that
they're right because you're harassing
them in the parking lot of a restaurant
and you won't let them get to their car
without you yelling at them. They're,
they're now saying,
you're unhinged and there's evidence
to prove that they've got a point.
You're like, no, no, no, no. It's
a, this is a never Trump movement.
We're a part of the movement and
we got together in person. Yeah,
you're making them angry and they're
going to harass liberals now and now we
have this giant conflict instead of just
communicating about important issues,
instead of just like trying to figure
out how we all get along, nothing,
how to solve problems and solve problems.
Digging your heels in
one team and the other.
You've got to try to solve problems,
but it's way easier. Persuasions,
the hardest thing, punishment,
destructions ways here. Here's the thing,
if they get him out of office,
here's the thing.
If they do succeed in getting them out
of office, those even more emboldened,
but my point is there'll be even more
emboldened that this is a correct way to
behave. Yes. I don't
think it necessarily is.
I think all of the things that are
calling out that are like ink with whether
it's, I don't understand the Russian
stuff. I've tried to go over it.
I feel like if there was like,
if there was clear enough evidence
that he had committed a crime,
they would have already
done so you'd be out. Yeah,
there's too much resource and time going
into it, but there's many indictments,
so there's other people around him that
have done something that was illegal.
This is, this seems to be very clear.
Right. Or at least had been accused,
so where it goes and Farley
Lik let that play out,
but that is a very different thing.
Then all of the,
the like the hatred and the
fucking going after people.
It's like you have to figure out where,
where the line gets drawn,
where you're causing internal conflict
that can literally lead to civil war. But,
but it's trickled down to,
into our economy of everyone's lives now
like on Twitter or in entertainment or
with the me too movement. Like it's
trickled down. It's a trickle down effect.
Well,
you know,
George Washington said one of the most
important qualities for a society to have
a civility and what does stability mean?
The founding fathers did not
agree on a lot of stuff. I mean,
Madison didn't agree
with, with uh, you know,
Hamilton and Jefferson,
they were very much at odds about
how to go forward with this republic.
But they talked it out.
They compromised nobody,
nobody got violent besides
Aaron burr and fucking
Hamilton later. But for the
most part, they compromised.
They talked and George Washington said,
civility,
the ability to listen to the other side.
We even when you don't agree with
them and put your ideas together,
that's how you move things forward.
We just don't have that anymore.
You just don't have it.
Right.
I think that's a really good point and
that's what bothers me the most about
this is not, not that they're not
corrected, there's some real problems.
It's the way everybody's going about it.
That makes me say like,
do you understand what happens
when you yell at people?
Like you can't just push people.
There's,
there's people that don't
understand violent consequences.
There's people that don't understand
conflict and they don't know how to
mitigate it and they don't know how to
like be calm and how to figure their way
through a situation.
There's dangerous levels of aggression
that get reached when you have like
Antifa feuding with these people that
are trying to do some sort of a speech
somewhere and there's the supporters of
the speech and then there's Antifa and
everyone's getting to get in screaming
and there's fire and bike locks and
people beating the shit out of each
other. All this stuff. There's,
there's plenty of videos to
this happening. This, this
doesn't have to end here.
Okay. This wasn't here five
years ago. Understand this,
that this could escalate in five years
to be significantly worse than it is now.
And me as a person who I, I'm,
I don't want violence around me,
I see that shit come in and I
go, oh, these guys are fighting.
Let's get the fuck out.
You don't want to go get close to them
and hope you catch a stray bullet.
And now the problem is that that five,
10 years,
like the problem is that conflict
comes to you. I mean, the problem is
it's unnecessary. It's not how we should
communicate with each other, you know?
And I think there's also people that
are emboldened by movements, right?
They get a,
they become a part of a movement and then
they want to do something to commit to
that movement. It's very similar
to joining a fucking militia.
It's very similar to joining resistance.
Media makes it easier.
Social media has made it
easier to find your tribe,
surround yourself with people who see the
world exactly like you do and organize
and attack the other shot with social
media. That's what makes isis kind of so,
so violent and also so scary
is because social media,
the first one's Kinda mastered
social media. My, my bigger worries.
Also the fact that people can't even
agree on the validity of their sources.
So if I say, well, you know, uh,
according to the United Nations or
the Bureau of Labor and Statistics,
and you go,
that's bullshit.
It's now I can't even get off the ground
because there's too much info. Right? So,
so I'm, I'm going through, I'm, if
I go to mainstream sources, you go,
that's mainstream and that's bullshit.
And they're bought off by corporations.
They have an agenda, came to
have an argument about, well,
here's something that I'm
trying to get better at it.
And I've worked on it a lot.
I try really hard to not be
connected to whatever I believe in.
And I try to not try
to win a conversation.
Those are two very important things.
So we hope to find it. Yes. But I'm,
I'm trying harder than I've ever tried
in my life and I've been on a path trying
to do this for years now and
getting better at it because of
just listening to podcasts, listen,
and having podcast and having conflicts
with people and trying to figure out why
I had those conflicts and
how much of it was my fault.
How much of it could have prevented,
how much have I could've done a better
job as a host or as a person who is
trying to relay the information and
through time I have tried my hardest and
it's something that concentrate on all
the time to not be connected to my ideas,
to argue them if I feel
like there's merit,
but argue the merit and not argue my
connection or emotional connection,
emotional connection to that claim.
So when someone does that, I get,
I get exhausted now because I
know where it's gone. I'm like,
we're going to waste a lot of time with
this because you're not willing to even
think about the possibility. I said the
last podcast it with Jordan Peterson.
I said, do you feel like
you're winning this debate?
Because at this point he'd
become so famous, and he said,
I don't want to win this because
I'm going to create resentful.
People feel like resentful losers.
That's not, that's not the point.
The point is to figure out
a way to present ideas so
that they are accessible to
the people whose minds
I'm trying to change.
This is exactly what he said
about Trump supporters. He said,
if you disagree with Trump supporters,
don't insult them.
That make them feel like
they're losers. Exactly. No,
that doesn't make anybody
feel good and you also said,
how do you think they're going to react
to that if you think they're just going
to give into you,
and he's a clinical site psychologist,
so we understand how he
understands how human brains work.
We do that immediately. What do we say
about Trump supporters? A lot of people,
this I really, they go, they're racists.
They're, they're, they're sexist,
transphobic, they're there most
all the haters and all this stuff.
Whereas maybe the LEP presented an
alternative that was unacceptable to them.
They didn't like this con man or this
guy was needless, but they were like,
let's give it a shot. I have 300 bucks
in the bank. I got no other options.
There's also that give people
the benefit of the doubt.
Most people are not assholes questionably.
There's,
there's both of those things and
there's some people that are out. Sure.
That's part of the problem is
that you run into enough of those,
those hurt your feelings and you think,
oh,
all Trump supporters are assholes because
I already know already though. Right,
but that's negative lens.
I feel like it's all negativity bias
is also something where our brains we
gravitate towards. If I get caught,
yeah, I'm not going to see my Instagram.
If you have a thousand comments
and 900 of her positive,
you'll see the one that you would know.
If you have 900 and you have
a hundred that are negative,
you're fucked and Super Fun. You're going
to read a hundred negative comments.
I'll say like you'll have a
million right along the competence,
but think about how amazing that
is that you have 90% positive.
In this crazy world. Oh, I know. So
things. All right, so if you have,
but your mind looks like, you know, your
mind goes towards the name of it. Yeah,
but what I'm saying is that the numbers,
as they expand,
they get more and more ridiculous.
So if you have a podcast,
the podcast gets a million downloads and
you get 100,000 negative comments and
900,000 positive. I was like, Oh,
have you looked at this as exhausting?
Have you looked at how, how many people
alcohol kills versus guns for example?
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
But nobody is talking
about banning alcohol.
You could really go into all
these details right there
because of obesity shortened lives because
of poor diet shows way more appealing
terrorism.
It kills a lot of fucking people.
And then there's also shit that happens.
Like we were talking about this recently
about Chicago, the violence in Chicago,
the numbers are so crazy and
no one seems to be flinching.
Like if those numbers were in
Beverly Hills, it's Beverly hills,
not the south side of Chicago.
If Beverly Hills had a thousand people
kill their shot in a year, we'd be like,
what in the fuck are you talking to?
Was Can we accept? We're like, God,
that's Chicago.
It's fucking crazy because the custom too.
It's like if a girl of chooses Charlie
Sheen of like spitting on her and doing
coke off her asshole you
like, yeah, that's what he
does. Of course what he does.
So if you hear others violence in
Chicago like Yup, that's what they do.
Hearing about that west side,
south side, we just like,
we liked the map to be discernible. Okay,
I know what this is. I know what that is.
Right. Keep it stat. Especially like
though, if it's something horrific,
like there's a Syrah serial killer,
so freaking the fuck everybody's out
knocking on doors. That's scary shit.
Chances of a Syracuse.
But there are also things that scare the
fuck out of you and that's where like,
I will not,
I will not go into the ocean and
swim where I can't touch the ground,
just done and it's stupid. It's
ridiculous. Smart move. Fuck. That place,
especially the Pacific was great ways.
Salah boot overrun,
overrun with great whites. San Francisco
is a fucking breeding ground, right?
That's going to San Francisco.
This guy, this guy, this
guy in Marina del Ray, he's,
he's swimming and he's got his hands
like tuck that aside like a seal and he's
going like this. He's diving in and I'm
like, Bro, you, you are stealing out.
You look like a giant smooth,
delicious seal right now.
Is that what you're saying? Let me, if
there's, if there's one bad ass way to go,
that's pretty sick and they
can see an end for sure.
Brazil got his dick bitten off. No.
Yup. Right through the crotch. Right?
The crotch. The Dick, the balls.
Asshole died. Bled out on the beach.
They bled out after the shark pit as Dick.
I'll take the, I'll take that cod. Hey,
meet me in half.
I got a peek.
I did a podcast where you got to watch
Jeff Garlin so sorry. I'm so sorry Kim.
The flattering when it comes back, we're
going to talk about actual fights over
hopefully hold holding please.
You get P two, but I'm like,
I can leave you by yourself.
I'll go after it.
I'll just talk about the constitution
guys. Fucking half a minute of your time.
You know the history of the Ottoman
Empire is very interesting. Actually.
We have to go all the way back though.
Can you imagine me just
fucking reading out of a book?
Why don't you plug your dates?
Plugging my days is anything
where it's when someone does that,
now that Joe's gone,
Hey Austin,
first week of August you will be there.
Right.
Um, now that you're taking
a break from the road, you
should come. I mean, surprise.
Some people maybe pick a city.
I do that come out and just open for you.
What about Vancouver?
One night,
September 13th if I'm
not shooting my Thursday,
my two TV shows and I thought you were
shooting in October. I'm so talented.
I forget. I'm shooting. I'm shooting
some of the Goldbergs I think August,
September, the last season
of goal bridge. I believe so.
And then I go and then I
think we started shooting.
I shoot one episode of schools and August
than the rest of October. Why? Just one?
It's just like a pilot. I
don't know. Yeah, no isn't, no,
just the way they do the schedule.
They want to figure it out. Yeah. Yeah.
Writing and stuff.
Writing and then when do you think you'd
go back on the road for stand up? Up,
get restless. I know it will happen
right now. I haven't thought about it.
That's the thing like I'll
like I'll go on whatever.
I'll be gone for every weekend of the
month and I'm like I need a break and then
I get one weekend off and like they
get back on the road. I knew miss it.
It's beautimous it. There's
nothing like it sometimes. Yeah,
sometimes it's beautiful.
Yeah. Sometimes it can be.
You can be in a city and it's terrible
but I just sometimes can be a little
rough. Yeah. I was
talking to Kelly because,
well you're going to be doing the same
thing cause count shot especially rights
and I didn't take a break from the road.
You shooting the show and I was saying
there's sometimes like a month ago in
this month coming up, I'm
on the road every weekend.
That's rough. It's rough. But,
and then I'm like, God, I need a break.
And then I get a break and have
like a week or two off. I'm like,
I need to get back on the road.
Like it's weird. You Miss,
this is my first break and 12
here, two weeks. But when you were,
let's say at my level in comedy,
you were grinding grindstone. Yeah.
You gotta, you gotta do what you gotta
do in the moment. You know when you're,
you're in that stage where you're
just trying to get those reps in too.
But I'm just saying like that you
missed the like, I'm like, God,
I need a fucking break this road,
man. Hotels and restaurants,
I need a fucking break. And I get back.
I'm like, I need to get back home.
It's weird. Love, hate
relationship. For 12 years.
It's the first time I've had a break
and I hadn't thought about it at all,
but it'll hit me and I'll start
to freak gay. He gets tired.
You get tired of waking up in hotel
rooms. Tired of flying. It's lonely. Sad.
I hate being out of my
routine. Yeah. That's what I
hate most. Your home routine.
Hate it. Yeah. I don't like that
either. But there's no alternative.
If you want to do big shows and you
want to go on the road. Do you want all,
I'm never stopped. Yeah. Not also.
I don't think there's an alternative
in terms of like creating material.
I think you need a bunch of different
kinds. You need Philly, you need Boston,
you need Florida. He need Miami too.
Occasionally you need to be like, oh,
there's some people that
just don't pay attention.
And the time alone sometimes
like just your, you know,
you gotta you gotta fill that day.
But I fucking love it cause I'm
just thinking and stuff. Dude.
You're a Bullock fucking calf muscle.
Most annoying muscle to pull cause it
doesn't heal because you're always on.
It takes awhile. Yeah. Oh such do you
do that fucking cunt elephants? No, no.
About two months ago I heard it and it's
never gotten back from running. Yup.
Oh yeah, now I to piss out, I'm still
run. I'll be right back. It's weird.
Can still run. Yeah. I could still
run. Um, but it's just, I feel it.
I could see that and I wonder what
the science is behind it that,
that I have a recurring injury,
right.
So I'll pull my lower back and my right
side or I'll pull my neck as a neck
muscle from wrestling probably
from years ago where I at.
Sometimes if sometimes I'll do something,
whether it's played tennis or box or
whatever, I'm fucking around and I'm,
I'm like, Oh fuck, I'm done for,
it's always the same side. Yeah.
I'm done for a week. Yeah. I bet a scar
tissue thing a bit. It's a mobility thing.
I bet that's one of the things and a bit,
you probably at some point in time had
a bulging disc and it's probably still a
little fucked up and you never got an
Mri and then, so you don't really know.
Right. That's interesting.
And I think, um,
that's one of the areas that a lot of
people don't strengthen is their spine.
You know,
I've spent a lot of time over the last uh,
few years using a bunch
of different exercises and
machines just specifically to
strengthen my spine and my core
after having some bulging back,
she was doing that.
I cured my lower back because of Lauren
Landau and my Buddy Leo, who helped me,
uh, kind of, uh, cause my
lower back hard for 20 years.
And they give me just some exercise
that I do every day and they're mostly
strengthening next time
they're not stretching the
strengthening your glutes and
stuff. I got no problems with my lower
back. I mean I cured my lower back,
which is kind of a miracle to consider
the idea that later on in my life.
But my neck is, uh, you know, and I do it.
I do neck exercises now you've got to
try this iron neck thing that I have out
here. I will, it's the fucking best.
Really? Yeah. He put a halo on your head,
you screw it on,
pull it on,
and then you pump itched like a Reebok
pump and I like fits tight to your head
and then you've got a bungee cord that's
attached to it that's 50 pounds and
you're back up with this thing and
then you do rotations like wow, really,
really good,
phenomenal.
But the most important thing is that
it's not dangerous and it's strengthening
your neck in the in a way where you're
giving it a full range of motion.
I want to do, I want to bottle and look
next. Don't get worked out that much.
Your lower back doesn't get worked out.
Then now she got to think like all the
other things are getting all these loads.
So when when you put a load on the
lower back and it's not strong enough,
that's when things go go out.
Yeah. If you strengthen it,
you can prevent a lot of that
stuff from happening. Right?
Like yoga is great for that. Yoga is
great for the back, great for the spine.
It's like one of those things you
realize when you're doing it like, oh,
these are muscles that I hardly ever
wear. Like what you do? Triangle pose.
Hardly ever worked that out yourself.
My jeans like to splash, bro.
Don't worry about it prompted my just
piss. It's a cute outfit on PP. Babies.
Kind of very colorful outfit. Yeah. You're
very hippy today. Twin bed. I left wing.
It's back. It's back. It's back. I
didn't know. I'm sure you get some title.
I should. No, I do have a tie back.
Got Sean O'Malley shirt
that I've worn that one
sugar straight on in the
house, baby. Oh Dude.
How about a fricking nick do a loss to
get them to the contenders. Read that.
I did not have a chance to watch the
fight. I don't want you can initiate it,
but I saw that, which is a bummer. I'm
rooting for like, I hope they win too.
It's interesting in chat was
the big story was that he lost,
not that the other guy won.
Like I kept reading that
he lost.
I didn't read that the other guy won.
I don't even know who the other guy is.
Me Neither. But I heard he's a bad ass,
but it's like, all right. You know
how crazy is that? Who Busy? Crazy.
Let's like you beat the guy with one
arm, but let's give the guys name. Maya.
My font was like how much bigger can you
be with the rest of your body if you're
like, how much? How many pounds was
the arm? It's just his forearm, right?
What'd you say, Jamie? Alex Munoz. Alex,
when Yo shout out to Alex Razor Blade man,
I heard it was a tough fight but nick
knew was a bad ass. You in the UFC? I, I,
I don't think the contender says is
right for them. Well, here's the thing.
A lot of the guys that are in the
contenders here is contender. Was,
is fucking excellent and a lot of guys
that are in that series is going to wind
up in the UFC anyway.
If you lose to one of them,
it doesn't mean that you're not good.
It means there's a luck.
The talent level's very high right now.
I would say up and coming back and
tennis shoes better and tough way,
but entertainment wise, and I am
close contender, she just kills it.
It's way better. Talent wise
does got tired. Oh tough.
Got Tired of this style or style of
coaching sauce. All the reality parts.
They're doing it again,
but I think they have to contractually
with Kelvin and Whitaker, right? Yeah.
I mean it's still, the fights are worth
watching. It's still worth it thought.
Some people like that reality TV
people still watch big brother Bro.
They love it. I see people tweeting
about big brother. I'm like,
what are you doing?
The ratings,
I mean the very few people are watching
tough these days. The Reagans are so bad.
What are the ratings that there's seven
people that watch this happen Bro.
And they also buy family everywhere
in hospitals. They to what?
No, I just think you know with,
with the contenders sees it,
it's Austin and making this push like
that's where you're getting your new young
talent. Yeah. I think that's,
that's what I want to say.
I don't want to see all the reality.
You know what the thing is that people
that like reality shows like it because
it allows you to have the reality shows.
Well cause the condensers is kicking
ass. Tough is not. That's fine.
I'm just saying Bro.
Yeah, that's a good point.
I think that to some people that don't
even know what's on the air anymore.
When the fuck do you hear
about an ad for that show?
The even the UFC is like work hood.
We're not putting any marketing in that.
We owe this last season. Just put two
fucking guys who will agree to do it.
Then how many but how much promotion you
see for Dana White's contender series?
Yeah, that's all over. Ratings are
way better. That's way better. Yeah.
Let's just say it's what
people want to see his fights.
They're going through a divorce
with Fox and then I can, all right,
well we're just going to live here til
December then we'll take our stuff,
get the fuck out. We're here. Right? You
can keep the dogs and then when you know,
we'll figure it out. It's so weird.
And even fox like posting stuff,
the WWE,
cause they're coming over to,
so they're flexing when they're new
side piece. It's so funny. It's,
but it's how many carry over audience
members are there from a UFC to WWE cross?
I don't. Yeah, I dunno. Fox
and give a fuck. Cause they,
what they know for sure as
you can control the narrative.
Wwe on those Friday night or Wednesday
night smack downs where the fuck they
call it bring in 3 million viewers every
single night and it's going to be chaos
and, but the end, they
can control the ratings.
They can control the superstars
and control everyone's destiny.
They know that fan base brings that no
matter what, UFC is not that. Right. Yeah.
So if you're fox is kind of
smart. Yeah, it is smart.
It works for both parties.
Fox in his just you're going to see money.
It's the way to go. Yeah. If you're
Fox, that's what we care about. Race,
the it go to just trying to make money.
I think the,
the thing about the contender series
though is that it's a bypass thing, right?
So it's all just good for the
UFC. Like what they own it. Yeah.
But also how many people are seeing that?
I don't know how many people watch it.
I think a five is 200 to
300,000 subscribers and
Tuesday night contender series
is only on fight pass and correct.
Do they release it ever on Youtube?
Why not be a bad idea? I lights. They
blast out and stuff. I don't know. But um,
yeah, I don't know. Yeah, it's, that's up.
That whole world of up and coming
talent has gotten so different.
The levels gotten significantly higher.
I see guys coming into the UFC for the
first time and I'm watching him fight.
I'm like, wow, this guy's
fighting. Like he's been here
for five years. I see, I see.
Yes and no. Some of it I looked at
your holy, how many fights do you have?
And they're like, just eight.
And he's that good. Jesus.
And then sometimes like you looked at this
Germany card which lasted seven hours,
which is a whole nother
topic we should discuss.
But when you in the eye look at some
and the difference between like say a
Robert Whitaker verse,
you all Ramiro versus you know,
some different cards where it's an
opening main card fight. The the,
the talent pool sometimes is so different.
Well that's just could be cards.
You know,
sometimes you get a card in the talent
pool and that card it's just not the
highest level.
And then you get other cards where like
you don't even know who the fighters are
and the talent's really hot,
insanely high.
My point is when you watch other
main professional sports, you don't,
you don't get that. No, no. I'm saying no.
But you also taught get your get volume.
Think about the volume of boxing
matches versus the volume of UFC cards.
It's not even close. The number of fights
that people are paying attention to.
Every card has 11 to 13 fights
and I think that's our problem.
Well the problem is it's a popular, it's
popular with people that want to do it,
these young bad asses that
want to prove they're the best.
There's a lot of them say it's spot, but
as far as contestants, people signing up,
signing up for is what's not poplars
people tuning into all these fights. No.
Now you asked the issue, you have to
make it special. Right? But do you,
because here's the thing.
Even if you just have a small number
that are tuning in every week,
say if you have fights every week
and 300,000 people watch like, oh,
this is a commercial disaster,
you still are building 300,000 people
and it's gonna be a different 300,000
people quite possibly next weekly. Some
of them are, at least some of them are.
You're going to have different narratives.
You got to have different fighters you
shine and then they're going to go off
into pay per view events. They're
going to go off into big ESPN events.
They're going to become household names
and that's where the is going to be made.
And so the, our argument is
the more she fights you have,
even if some of fights
that aren't doing well,
you are still allowing a really
high level of competition.
These fucking assassins merged through
the top these Darren tills and these Yoel
Romero's and all these fucking killers
come to these Bora cina fucking eraser
versus Yoel Romero.
Oh my stuff versus team.
All body first team, all body,
both guys crazy muscular it.
I'm not mad at you, your whole
body. I mean extreme. But
Joseph, to your point too,
back to your point where your saturation
saturation in the market and you're
hoping that the superstars come out
of there that's not working. Well,
here's the thing. There's a cycle
and I think this is a cycle,
the same way as a cycle
of predators and prey.
Do you know if they have
like snowshoe hares and lynx?
There's a cycle where the snowshoe hares
get to a very high number and the links
eat them all and then the links get to
a very high number and they run out of
snowshoe hares and the lynx dropped down
again and the snowshoe hares come back
up.
This is the natural cycle.
And you're saying the cycle is going
to be the suit like a Conor Mcgregor,
Ronda Rousey Brooklyn's. There's always
something. There's always someone,
there's always someone who rises to the
biggest draw right now in the UFC for
sure. [inaudible] second. Besides,
besides him, George Saint Pierre,
if he wants to fight George St Pierre,
especially just wimpy Connor Brock,
George, those are your three. Castro's
Brock would not be Conor at this stage.
I'm saying one, two, three. Right.
But if the UFC was around,
I mean if we were at the
stage where Brock was like,
say before he beat Frank Mir,
like when,
when when he was the heavyweight champion,
when Barack was just smashed it,
he was a,
he could sell what was like the highest
pay per view with Brock and I think it
was like 2 million. The third highest
honor in Nate's first. Yeah. So it's,
it's in that light. UFC wasn't as
popular then, I don't think as it is now.
But they, they did the dub dub.
He had the Wib fanbase crossover.
But what's interesting to them,
a lot of people don't, you know,
there's a reason why,
but the demand for Nate Diaz too,
cause remember he's part of the biggest
paper you all time with Connor Mcgregor.
So ideas isn't that tier two.
You can go Connor Brock, Rhonda,
Nate's four or five.
It's number two,
UFC 100 Brock Lesnar versus Frank Mir.
1,600,000 bucks.
That's a lot. It's only 50,000 different
than Nate Diaz versus Conor Mcgregor,
which is number one. That's pretty
crazy. Those numbers are crazy. So, um,
and then Conor Mcgregor, Nate Diaz,
Conor has one, two, three, four, five.
Misha Tate is amazing at UFC 200.
So you had Brock Lesnar.
Brock has a Shitload, Brock as one,
two, three out of the top seven.
And Ronda comes in at number eight.
They're in their own.
They're on their own stratosphere,
right?
Like they don't toss them in there.
Nate's right there. Yes. Number one.
Number three, that Amanda Nunez, Ronda
Rousey got a million million one.
Nate Diaz. That's arguably because he
was fighting Conor McGregor. Right? Well,
and that's why it hasn't taken
a fight because that's the, the,
that trilogy is the biggest one.
The biggest. That hasn't happened.
I mean, it is the biggest, it's the
biggest. If con, here's the thing,
if Connor comes back and decides
to fight Khabib, that's a fight.
It's going to be a gigantic,
enormous,
biggest paper view of all time and
if they decided to do it in Russia,
fucking insane. And I'll be
watching from here with you guys.
We're doing a companion for us for sure.
Rochelle huck on the run,
so that'll be our biggest companion ever,
by the way is adas
pulled me aside like two,
we're going to do some big things in
Russia. I'd really like you to come like,
because like fuck out outta here man.
I ain't go to Russia.
Cut to me for around my face.
I love it in Russia. That's why.
Amazing. Yeah. The problem is that trip,
that trip insights, it's a long term
past. Nobody here with you guys.
I'd rather be here with you guys anyway.
It's more fun. Kind of fine. Could be.
I really like being there live. Don't
get me wrong. I love it. I love the job,
but I'm going to be honest. It's more fun
watching the fights with you guys. Yeah,
for sure. Of course. Just not even
close to French. They didn't even clap.
We can get wine. Yeah.
Having cheese and kidding.
Pissing people off because you chew it
on the microphone. Yeah, that's true.
It's the most fun until we get into the
illuminati stuff so I can keep any on
tape. Luminato sharp left. I even enjoy
that. I get to be on, I Miss Eddie,
but Eddie done. Now he doesn't
drink. He doesn't drink. No,
he doesn't drink anymore and
he's way more reasonable. Well,
like with that kind of stuff. He's not
an evolution, but I mean other than that,
I don't know if that's true. I haven't
really talked to him about that. I just,
I'm just reading his Instagram is to,
they announced the big flight.
Mike Perry Serone. Ooh. My parents are
in Denver. That's crazy. That's a great,
that was good. Good fight. That's
crazy. Five fricking great. Yeah.
He's dangerous, man.
He hits fucking whore.
Plus his last fight against Paul filled.
Are you mixed it up. You started,
you started fighting. Smart. Dealt with
a real camp and Jackson's it's damn good.
Yeah. Is that Jackson, Jackson,
Jackson Jackson crime with the cowboy.
He said he was essentially running his
own camp training himself before Railey.
Yup. Yup. And when you're
watching him fight,
now you're seeing what's matter Woodley
Til. That's the other one I forgot.
But you're seeing him now in his
last fight against Paul Felder,
he looked more polished.
He looked more professional and as
a pro look completely different.
Still got all the Marauder.
He's still a fucking killer.
Still super aggressive knockout artists.
Like when stores controlled more strategy
go up to 70 when it was just for that
fight. It was just, they gave him
an option. You can shorten it,
but he would have done so tough.
We been way better in that fight if he
didn't break his arm in the first round
until I saw it, I was like,
dude, I don't like that.
When it bounced off his head
when it bounced off Perry's
head, I was like, dude,
that might be a broken arm.
I thought cry.
Cause there's a lot of people like Paige
van Sanchez had a second surgery on her
arm because of that. She had
a lot of shit, more surgeries.
This caught up a kid.
I was like this, I don't know if I should
do I do that. I don't know what to do.
The bone is not, it's not
easy to hit something with
your, especially a forehead.
Yeah. This park, this shit snaps man.
You know this is,
I'm,
I'm really surprised we don't have more
guys getting their forearms broken in.
Blocked in blocking kids. Yeah, because
there's some guys that just fun.
That's right. To break your arm
a little bit. It fell or fell.
There is um, it's such a, I
think he's a high level striker.
He's really super high, so fucking good
man. But look, he is, he is a smaller guy.
Mike Perry's Mike Perry is a way more
scary one strike artists even though it
felt really scary.
55.
You lose a little bit of that when you
go up against the bigger guys. You just,
you just going til stood his ground toe
to toe with that guy. Highly skilled.
He's very smart.
We highly skilled like his arms,
that version of Perry Hill
and then we saw it. It's like,
oh fuck that verse before.
It's one of his most technical opponents
like that pair of shows up against
cowboy. We get like, okay, here's the
fight with the allonge Oban fight.
Alan Jobe band, who's was fought a
smart technical fight. Outpointed Perry,
and the way y'all pointed Perry, y'all
pointed Perry. That was more obvious.
It was a different Perry hunting. Just,
yeah, just boring one dimensional.
He was trying to just
put those hands on it,
but now you see a guy who
was trying to do that,
but with like some Winkeljohn
strategy coach and he's young.
He's only like 26 right? He's gonna
be a problem. We've a lot dangerous.
Super Crystal, Bro. I am
stunned. I'm stunned EOC talking about
Colby just had to get a nose operation for
sinuses,
but this the thing Colby goes and I
spoke to someone very close to Colby.
Colby goes, dude, I'm down for the
fight. I just went five rounds.
Willie's been up for, how long? Give
me, I can do it in October, November.
Just let me get ready. I just said, I'm
going to have science fair. And they went,
nope. Stripping of the belt until you
want it until it's like, fuck yeah,
I'll take it.
See that.
That seems to be a problem for anybody
that's considering taking interim title
fight in the future.
That's what Ryan Ortega,
Brian Ortega saw that and he was like,
listen,
they're offering him before that when
his flight got canceled because Max
Holloway, it was running to
all those medical issues.
They offered him a fight for the interim
belt and I think it was against Jeremy
Stevens is fighting this weekend.
They offered frank Yeager and
Jeremy Stephens and so he, Frankie,
everyone's crazy. That doesn't even make
any sense. That's what Brian saying. Yeah,
and so then Jeremy and Jeremy
Stevens is fucking dangerous. Yes,
he is talking about a guy
sleeping dangerous for anybody.
He's doing such a good fighter
for anybody. He and he is
guns blazing. He's fine.
Although this weekend so on, I know
that's a great fight. So I'm 55 right,
those 40 45 so they offered him all those,
those 49 offered him Ortega the offered
or take a fight with Jeremy because
Jeremy is already cut and wait
for this fight or you know,
at training for this fight, which is only
a few weeks later. And he says, well,
it's interim title. It doesn't mean
anything. I want the real belt fighters.
Don't take it serious. Well here's
why they shouldn't now. Right.
Well this is a basic example.
Like why would I fight for interim belt?
You just strip Kolbe. Now
this is us assuming that we
know the whole store. Right?
I don't know the whole story.
I haven't talked to Colby.
I haven't talked to Dana Jacoby, but
I don't, I think the conversation,
I'm not a fan of the idea of an interim
title unless there's extenuating
circumstances.
Like someone's got a broken leg,
they have to be out for six months, but
it should be a year. If they had a year,
you got to do something so you
wouldn't lose out a year. Correct.
So that's why it made RDA. It made
sense. And also just to play if I'm Dana,
if hey Woodley,
we need you to fight and you want
the super fights turning down fights,
what can we do? Let's force the
Sand Creek. This interim belt,
he's been out a year, which I
like. I wasn't talking about that.
I was talking about Brian
Ortega. Okay, Gotcha.
Let's talking about Brian or Tayga
because Max Holloway's defended fairly
recently and he was getting
ready to fight Khabib.
It's not like he's been out a lot.
They offered him that could be fight.
He tried to cut weight for it and he
might have fucked himself that way.
Is that what it was? Yeah,
it's entirely possible.
They're still trying to figure
out what happened. Well,
one of the pieces of speculation is that
his body started shutting down because
he went through a real bad cut for the,
when he was trying to make the
[inaudible] at 55 on super short notes.
That's a hard thing for him
to make. 55 is a huge, huge,
he's 25 he's like one 85 yes,
dude. Max is a big fella.
Brian or Tayga is fucking huge to take
them on to take it goes up to 85 I
couldn't really, I stood next to him. I
was like, how big are you? How is bigger?
Holly's bigger and so this is
the problem with these guys.
They need a lot of time to get
down to this weight. Right?
So how all the way trying to do that.
This is what, this is pure speculation,
Holly, we tried to do that
is it was very hard for him.
His body broke down and then in
cutting weight for this fight,
once his body started the water load,
his body knew what was going on.
It started shutting down.
This is speculation, pure
respect, but here's my point.
You can't make me till you know that
he's going to be out for a certain amount
of time. It seems like an interim
title belt is almost disrespectful.
Like he's,
he's the champ makes zero sense,
but I think it's like it was
a corporate decision find out,
but I feel like it was a corporate
decision that they went, okay,
we have to fight. We need
to fill this gap. We have to
fight. Well they asked if I,
somebody of course we get,
you're talking about some different yeah,
but I'm saying, I'm saying they go, they
go, we want this gotta be a of fight.
How about this?
How about you have this,
how about you give the Colby retains
his interim title because there's
extenuating circumstances with him
medically. He had to get nasal surgery.
He's out until November.
Colby gets the next shot.
Whoever the fuck wins his fight.
Colby fights next. Yes. Dream. I see,
but you haven't talked to your boy Dana.
Maybe he's saying that maybe every same
stripped there saying you bebe, listen,
fuck your belt, but you
will get the next shot. Who?
Everyone's just taking your buy at
hers and they were trying to do some,
well maybe it was Uzma Uzma and wants
to fight till next and he's like,
let's do this for the real
number one contender spot.
Cause Uzman is a guy who has quietly been
beating everybody they put in front of.
Yes he has. And I love him. His last
fight, I wasn't the most exciting.
But if you go through,
you know who my has fought,
you look at the way Colby
did it prior to that,
you know you Uzman would have the worst
argument but he has the eye the most
potential probably like he's like no one
wants to fuck off for the Damien Maia
fight. I wouldn't agree with you cause
both guys beat Damien might before.
That was not good. I'm saying other
decisions right. It's not like he was,
he wasn't dare telling people. I met the,
before the Damien Maia fight with Colby,
Colby didn't have a lot of
big names on his resume.
He hasn't one decision over Damien
Maia. Yeah. So like what do we got here?
I beat Damien Meyer as
well and his last fight,
although there was a thing about that
fight that bothered me. Two things. One,
the referee chose to separate Damien
Maia from ou smiled when he had him from
behind.
The wizard.
Dude was a fucking compromising
position in your submission.
That was I,
this is not [inaudible] fault.
This is just the referees fault I serve.
I severely disagreed and agreed with
Matt Serra who was talking about the guy
takes the fight on short notice.
He gets to a good position.
You're telling them to work. You gotta
be careful not to lose a position.
You're talking about a super high level
wrestler in Eastmont who you can't just
let go and it was very
worldclass grap like Damien Maia,
he needs one nano second for
Huseman to make a wrong turn crowd.
The crowd boos,
you can't get upset.
There's a situation that's happening
with this guy has the best chance of
winning and he's,
he's at the door.
He's at like step eight out
of 10 he's got the back,
but he might go to nine and then
it was mine might try to defend.
He might go to 10 and get the
tech correct. Entirely possible.
This is happening right now. I don't know
how it was. Sounds 70 by the way, but
even with this Uzman so god damned good,
but you look at one 70 what's,
where's the fireman? Why does everyone
have to fight for the title right away?
Let's not kill off all these.
I think one of the things is because
they want that they need stars. Yeah.
They want that paper view card to
have a big headliner and you know and
Woodley's ready.
You can create that with
trilogies with great fights with,
I mean there's a way they seem to be
a better strategy than to feed her,
but that's, if you didn't have
a schedule that you had to fill,
see boxing's different in that.
Boxing doesn't have a schedule
they have to fill that way.
Who's making the schedule? Why do that?
To fill that schedule? I Dunno man.
100 fighters on staff.
Will they commit to us?
You they have to commit to
certain amount of fights. Right.
With Fox and paper view picture of Vituro
standing with Dana in front of their
fucking board of fighters and trying
to figure out who fights. Who. No,
I've got a headache. I almost blacked
out. Just looking at the board.
A hard drinking about 500 fighters.
You're responsible for putting into
fights and how many people in Sean Shelby
and Mick Maynard and they're
running around Joe Silva's
in his underwear rolling
around with his buddies and, and Joe Silva
fucking Virginia laughing his ass off.
I was still, he's like, I
got out bitch. Yeah. He goes,
I'm doing karate in my basement,
but just reading books and chilling.
Mick mic Maynard and Sean Shelby
with 10 fucking uh, and you know
Silva, Joe Silva's, all the three
of them have one thing in common.
All Merce super smart dude.
Yeah, yeah. For shows.
Matchmake it's not like there's
like, Oh let's do this. They're very,
very smart guys. Learned about a
lot of books from Joe Sova. Look at,
look at that board and look at
all those names and that board.
Something that doesn't give you the
top 15 that's still gives me a headache
really in every weight class.
It gives me a fucking headache.
It doesn't give you a headache. Yeah.
Cause they're not all called get ranking,
dude.
All those guys we can figure out
the match on and it takes you long.
And then some of them take
care of themselves. One to
Europe, the [inaudible].
I mean it's between driving
Ferrari's and making deals.
You don't have time to make these matchups
got to prove you have time to hate on
people. On Instagram. You've
got time. Oh, hate on people.
That's the hardest timers.
Those numbers,
those numbers give me a goddamn
headache. Yeah. Who's going to fight?
Who Gets Chris?
That's easy part really freaks me out.
This is one of those people have his
phone number and text him all the time.
Probably not got that many. Just
taking my phone buzzing. No, no.
That seat. What's crazy?
If you think this is easy,
you went through 1515 through
fucking 100 complicated part
number 50 guys gonna
fight 43 where they fight.
When he put them fly him in from
Brazil, you're not ranked. Right?
So until you crack that top
15 nobody gives a shit. Yeah,
but you still got to get matchups
for him. He got a match, a match ups.
And how often are you getting those
matchups you getting in a fight once a six
months. Once a year. You know,
he's given some risk on the left.
They have the pound for pound
rankings. Hmm. That's very strange.
Mm hmm. Yeah. It almost mirrors
completely the website though.
Like that's the very first who was
fighting cris Cyborg soon or that does,
yes. Supposed to descend together
and works pissed about it.
She wanted to do September, but a man
I knew it says to wait til December,
but she's done. She said she put some
weight on Shit. She needs time to,
she gonna fight her on sideways
and not happy about it.
Why did she want to fight
in September? Cyborg. She,
she fights once every year and she's
like, let's go man. But she also goes,
all right, well if you're like,
give me that. Give me someone else.
I don't want to wait till December.
I can plate bolts but fight me.
If a Cyborg does decide,
um,
to like to leave the UFC,
are they going to be able to get her
fights somewhere else? It doesn't matter.
You'll see. He's like in
her fights. Right. But who
else is going to be able to,
it's not gonna be easy for her wherever
she goes. No where she goes. No, no,
too good. Yeah. Well, two good.
And also there's a lot of
[inaudible] 45 yeah. I mean,
you saw big Megan Anderson looked Meagan,
excuse me,
looked when she fought Holly. Holly Holm.
I mean she looked a lot bigger than her.
He gave her a warm up and then had her
fight Cyborg. That would have been better.
I wouldn't kill her off with Holly Holm,
who's this animal because now you don't
have a competitor for Cyborg and answer
would've been a fun one for Cyborg.
We did think that, you know,
Meghan is physically very big, very
strong, likes to stand up and bang,
but now like at least a part of her game
for that fights been pretty exposed.
That's to be honest. First find the
UFC fight and Holly, Holly Holm,
I know what she did get kind of wrestled
and dominated and on the ground by
Hollywood, which is not, you
know what I mean? So you're
like, hmm, that's, but still,
it's like
that was a plan for that
fight to Cyborg needs.
But cyborg needs more like stars
in competitors. Like stories.
Why kill one off with Holly?
Oh, 100% but the thing is like,
at least that's a fight where
there's a name and a name.
So I can sell some pay per views with
that fight. Well, for Holly at least,
I mean it's like Megan Anderson at least
has some hype behind her. She comes in,
it's a good fight for hall. Holly took
a big risk taking that fight tests.
You know what if she loses, you know, bad
situation and going up to 45 you know,
staying at 45 when she's a
legit $30 sideboards, I going
to fight Holly. She goes,
no, you just don't beat that girl and
get a rematch and, and I just beat you.
So who fights are now? Yeah. So now
you're in the situation where we're like,
all right, let's call up
a men and Nunez, right?
Fighting Cris Cyborg is very
intriguing to me. Way More dangerous.
I think that's going to be more
dangerous than one way more damage.
But she never fought anybody that
anybody cyborgs ever fought. Correct.
Other than Gina than that Thai girl.
Oh,
shoring a barge. You know,
she, she knocked her down
with a front kick to the face.
I would say a prime.
Holly's more stronger because Holly
and Holly can get up to that weight.
Amanda knows me. She's coming up.
She's smaller, you know. I agree.
Yes. Yeah, for sure.
Holly is awesome and super highly skilled
and a counter striker stylistically is
more dangerous. Cyborg and cyborgs
beat her pretty candidly. Yeah.
Maybe if she followed me.
Holly is a little older.
She's like 36 now manifests coming
forward and cyber coming forward there to
Mack trucks. One's a way
bigger fucking Brazilian truck.
What do you think's going to happen?
I didn't know I,
that's a really good point cause
I didn't know. I feel like, uh,
Amanda Nunez is his shoulders.
Why? She just looks everybody
no small and she does press
forward relentlessly against that.
Here's the thing,
she doesn't have to fight that way.
We're assuming that she
has to fight that way.
You tell me she didn't use
the footwork like Holly. Well,
she used to a lot of foot work in great
hands, great hands. She punches hard.
She punches long arms,
long arms and punches hard. You know,
as long runs and punches harder,
hurt inside board. There's not a woman
alive is the greatest of all time.
It's definitely dangerous fighter.
I think Amanda Nunez has more technique,
but I think when you come up like that
and you have this animal Cyborg, it just,
I think, scary. You get Claressa shields
to learn how to sprawl. You were seeing,
she holds her. Jamie bring up
Chrissa shields and Cyborg sparring.
Yeah. Oh, that black guy that she
was a champion. Black black boxer,
black curl curl, and he said,
God, thank you. Said Gus,
they guy. My manager made
a mistake. Like sometimes I
say, Brian are really no,
she's amazing. She can bang.
They I'm boring and they bang. Bang. Now.
Now Imagine Dema nother
professional female founder.
You can get down like zero. Oh, and
she's an Olympic medalist. Brian.
The two times I watch this. Let's watch
a little of this. Yeah, there's zero.
I would pay money for you to jump in
there with either one of these girls. No,
thank you. I'm not hurt. Yeah,
I just want to see me. Look at,
look at her fucking skill level.
Like the way she's waiting with a counter
with straight shots and use that jab
and go to the body and then up to the
head. Chris is doing work. Oh yeah.
Chris Landress man,
she's fucking dangerous.
And Claressa correct me if I'm wrong.
I believe she fights it a heavier weight.
Yes. No, you're right.
I think she fights at 65 is that what her
weight class and she's the best female
box in the world, right? Yeah. And
look at her fucking counterstrikes.
Look how she goes to the body and to the
head can get that to that right to the
body and right over the top. And she's
on Cyborg to Matt. They're throwing down,
dude. She's winning the rounds. But cyborg
is holding her own is my point. Oh yeah.
And by the way of Cyborg Cyborg could
kick her legs. Claressa would be,
I'm just saying when we talked
about the Amanda Nunez fight,
we talked about her standup.
It's like I get that sideboards,
very big man and deals with
high level boxes for sure
is my favorite female fighter.
The only difference is
Claressa is standing right
in front of her and pressing
her and she's trying to put it on her.
I don't think Amanda Nunez Smart Strategy
would be to fight this with the best
strategy would be to use the aggression
of Cyborg and try to counter and glance
when she can and get out. Has she ever
fought that way before though? Well,
can she can't. She was smart
enough. Matt Brown is a genius.
She fought real slick
against Raquel Pennington.
He wasn't just packing and mauling.
What I say he said Matt, but Mike, Mike,
Mike, Mike Man. Mike's crushed.
He has champion in his own right.
Great fighter himself. Yeah, some
lost to his hook. Josie Alto money.
A lot of money. Dan Lambert put a
lot of money in American top team.
That mother fucker.
If it wasn't for him,
it wasn't for Dan Lambert
and his contributions to the
state of MMA would be a s
a percentage or two lower than it is now.
I couldn't agree more.
It's a big no,
no a lot.
He took him under their wing and brought
them up and they just built a new place.
He put in dormitories, built a giant
gym, like built it from the ground up,
bought a piece of land to
put a fucking structure up.
He's a monster beast and amazing
Dan Lambertson the animal,
they need to put him in the
UFC hall of fame. No bullshit.
No one should be in some sort of MMA home.
So I mean if guys like at least think
about double the amount of money that he
had to invest that time he had taken
the fact that it wasn't making any money
out of it.
It's a passion project pass.
He lost a lot of money and he got fucked
over by a bunch of people to that real,
no need to name names, but
he'll, he'll tell you personally,
he got fucked over by a bunch of
guys that he trusted and over the,
over the years he learned who could
trust and who you can and develop this
incredible school and this incredible
Jim and I mean it's one of the best
facilities on the planet earth when it
comes to MMA training and keep people,
many high level guys. Yeah.
Unbelievable. Yeah. This is it right now.
I mean it's crazy,
phenomenal, phenomenal gym.
But it's [inaudible] investment.
The fact that he had the balls to put the
money up for something like that long,
long ass time with it.
The first time I ever saw Hector Lombard
and I walked across the mat and I,
I'd never quite seen anybody that thick
and, and he had, he was not Cuban.
Jean saw those Yoel Romero was,
he fight out and they were like,
at the time it was 85 and I didn't
believe it. He says another things.
I'm just up rice and beans
and garlic. Chicken. No,
Hector, Hector. You ever have
that garlic chicken from dude?
God Damn,
that Shit Love Cuban food to man.
They have that garlic chicken with
onions or the lemon sauce to my,
now my mouth is watering smell of it.
I've been doing that fucking a Cuban
slash cans and rice on the side. Come on.
John Culture. I love Cuba. I love cute.
I like the Calorie counting or knows
Joey does, but I love, no, not my job.
I love Cuban Miami and Miami is great
because it because of the Cubans.
It's a big part of it for sure.
For sure. There's such a blast. Oh,
that's 30 inches.
I fucking love him.
I love him to make the best
cigars on the planet earth.
Everybody knows that and good looking,
not so hard to get anywhere.
They used to be like
get a serious thing once
you get some fake ones too.
There's a limited amount of land that
grow it on the the most precious land.
I think it's something ridiculously
small. Cigars. Yeah. Yeah.
I think there's the VA,
VA whole a Baha'i.
What is the name of the area? There's
one area where they grow these happy,
I don't care.
We're going to find out the soil.
There's something really
special but special.
Something about the mineral
content in the soil yet.
That way you can buy a plot of land here
and the wines like 30 bucks a bottle
for whatever reason because of where the
sun hits. And what time just over here,
like the next plot over. It's worth like
the vines. Yeah. It's $100 bottle of wine,
a Bajo and the semi VL tow regions.
So the Pinata del Rio province,
it's located at the western end of Cuban
contains the view view, view El Da.
That VL to a Bajo is
where everybody wants to.
Guards from nowhere in the world
grows tobacco better than Cuba Lounge.
So that area though grows these cigars.
Like if you ever had a really
good like Hoyle Demana Ray,
double corona for have Havana,
this is what you want to do bro.
You want to eat a fat steak?
I got fat Ribeye. My mouth is.
And do you carpeted that nearby?
You sit there with a double espresso to
guy than a ridiculously fat cigar that
gets you high after two pumps.
Ah Yeah. Yes. Cuban cigar.
But here's the of drug tigers at my feet
so I can squish my Phoenix drugged up
task quilts. Yes. Yeah.
Nichold up fucking tag
all heroin mountain guys.
You ever seen those guys roll those
cigars? It's pretty impressive.
It's a skill thing isn't
craftsmanship thing. Yeah there's not,
it's not simple like rolling a joint. I
thought it was done between shot fat too.
Beautiful, beautiful Cuban
Cuban. Are these people doing it?
They, they're skilled man. They,
they know which tobacco leafs to
take and how to put it together.
And what you put on the outside is
different than what's in the inside.
And this fucking one guy was watching at
the airport some place near the airport
rather where they would roll cigars.
Are you going to go and watch them do it?
And it's like you stand in front
of the windows. Dude puffing us.
So this was in Miami. I
went with Joey Way, way,
way back in the day.
There was a place where you could go
where you could watch some people roll
cigars and so they would, they would
roll the cigars in front of you,
impress him and put it all together.
Just like this guy here,
he had like a few
moisture. Yeah. But dude,
it's impressive because their skill
like that. Well the craftsman,
yeah,
they knew how to do it.
Like he's trimming it and they're doing
it all by hand and by feel and he knows
how much to put in the cigar.
Like look at this.
So now he's sitting in front of him.
This, this way. Your smoke. Yes.
So he's rolling that bitch up.
Oh look.
See he's broken it all up by hand and
he's getting his finger wet and wet and
down the [inaudible].
Yeah dude,
it's seriously skilled labor and you've
got to think this guy might be rolling.
Beautiful hands.
I have a question.
Might be rolling 20 of those
in the same box and look,
see at cuts it with that knife man.
Oh fuck yeah.
I have a question. Pinches
it down. Seals the end.
This is beautiful man for you think
he's doing extra because the cameras are
there. No, no, no. This is how they do it.
I want to still be pro and
then this is the outside,
so that's the inside of the leaf.
Then they take the outside.
So that is the outside, which
is, what do they call that shit?
What do they call it? The outside of
the leaf is a wrap. Is it the rap?
I think they call it the rap.
So they,
he trims it to perfect size and then he
gets this bitch up there and it rolls up.
Mother fucker at that gets
pedicle it tight. You fuck.
Look at how he's like backing it up and
slow it down and add a little moisture.
Here. Let me get my hand on
my pants. Keep talking. Yeah.
These guys are skilled laborers. I
mean this is, do you guys love cigars?
I do enjoy a cigar every now and again,
but not like you're not doing it every
Friday night or some shit. Hey, you're,
you're a chronic drug store. I have a
question. You're a pop kind of sore. Um,
though I was thinking about this. They
sprayed out. Fuck. Got a weed, right?
They spray it with lots of pesticides do.
Then I believe that a lot.
Like you should talk to
Gino. No, I actually have.
I actually have it on good
authority. Oh Shit. What's up Laura?
It's like pesticides or
organic pesticides as a whole.
I have it on good authority that when
you're buying a lot of ways they sprayed
the whole because it's,
it's valuable and it gets moldy,
so they will spray it to death.
Then it doesn't really get washed.
You're you're s from from my,
when you do it in bulk,
you're buying people who deal
in this stuff in big bulk.
They kind of money,
money spread and then you smoke that.
I wonder what that does. I
wonder. Fun. Those things.
Got The weed. Fuck your
pathetic. Asking a question.
Fuck you. Pesticide. I just
come on smoke yet. Yeah,
but I think as much squash it. I don't
think they do. They definitely don't.
You think though, you're seeing
those go. How about this?
How about this?
When you're counting $1 million when you
have this money counters and you're in
a room and they're kinda like there
cause a lot of is this cash, right?
Guess what you gotta touch one. You might
want to go in there with a mask. Why?
Number one you can actually get a runny
nose from the cocaine residue and you
get sick cause the, the, the
dirt that comes off money.
Have you ever seen what they found
on money? They found shit. I'm money.
First of all, every, every dollar
bill has some residue of cocaine.
Like every like not just dollar bills.
22 yes, yes. But forget all that.
They found that this guy did this now son,
a bunch of different telehealth.
They even found White Rhino Horn powder
on all fun and just a bunch of the bills
because it gets, you know the
number of times that it's, you know,
but they found crazy shape rhino.
They found cocaine,
they found all kinds of weird
party and broke the rhino powders.
The weirdest and that weird cause cause
probably some poachers are dealing,
turning back and forth.
Here's the thing about the rhino thing.
There's nothing that shows that
that does anything. No, no.
We were talking about the bear bile.
The Rhino thing just fucked up.
That's the craziest thing. Soltes killing
rhinos. Just like almost to say, oh,
this tea is made out of dead rhino.
Come have a seat. Right. We are.
We are very fancy gentleman.
We were drinking rhino tea,
so you're telling me if you're weird.
It doesn't make me think he's up.
If someone's like, dude, we got Rhino
Horn, Tia like, well, you know what man,
if you're far enough removed from the
actual source of the misery and you don't
actually see the Rhino get shot in the
head and his horn hacked off and you just
think you're a fancy guy with a gold
Rolex on drinking some rhino tea. Yeah.
You know what I mean? There's a lot of
that elusive and want to be exclusive.
They love it and I think it was called,
what is it called?
The Green Hills of Africa,
I think it's called the Hemingway book.
And he describes killing a rhino and a,
it was done back then.
And what's your second one,
Bro? Oh yeah. Getting nuts.
Start throwing up in that in the fucking,
in the heat just flew from the other side
of the planet Sun. Part of what a weak,
why I went and bought all that weed last
week is because the new rules came into
place. Test for pesticide. Ooh.
They had six months, which is,
I guess it started as so Jamie's like,
give me that pesticide covered. We'd son,
I don't want you to bullshit ass clean.
We like it. He's just now starting,
so that makes sense.
Well,
we smoked is what I've been smoking a
lot lately as blunt with the tobacco on
the outside. On the
inside. Yeah. I stuck that
poor pink lungs. No, get a little buzz on.
It's like a whole cigar type down now.
We'll blow buzz you not doing it every
day. Right now I'm hooked on cigarettes.
Thanks Joe. Well, um, I got back in,
you would again with Chappelle Chappelle
smoked one with me and I was like, dude,
I'm like elevated here. He goes, it's
nice right there. Go. It's weird. I go,
it's like the tobacco
mixed in with the weed.
I forgot about it and the last time
I had really smoked one before.
That was a with Charlie Murphy.
What does that say? Jewel user sue.
What over the addictive e-cigarette.
That's given him too much nicotine so
they fucking babies. Well, let just stop.
Last time I saw Chappelle,
he was in the back is using
one of the fucking vapor pens.
Here's my doctor says this way. Ben
Island. Have you ever looked into that?
Because that's not, they don't know for
sure if it's that much better for you.
Vaping? Yeah. Yeah. I
don't know if it's better,
but I know a lot of people
say it's better. I don't know.
It's right. What is your,
you aren't getting smoked with a vape,
but it's,
but that's vote right in that smoked
like in that container. There's alcohol,
there's all sorts of weird
shit and fuck that stuffs.
Well that's the thing
with those we'd ones too,
I ran into some due to told me he
makes it with MCT oil. Yeah. Okay.
Well why not? I'll smell oils. Oil.
I guess you are ingesting
it in your lungs. Yeah.
Yeah. You're, you're doing something. I'm,
I'm getting into psychedelics have
decided you've decided I'm not kidding.
We did DMT together. When I do it again
and all of that. I want to do acid.
I've never done that. I've done
mushrooms many times. You know what? No,
I like it to him in life.
I'm getting into meditation.
I'm getting into meditation to zoom.
Do you want to use attention once you use
the tank? I've done that. My Ego Dude,
you can let go of your ego. It's
right here for you. You want,
remember the one time we used the
tank in San Francisco? Yeah, I do,
Bro. Not For me. Get Bad. Brennan
decided you're free to say it.
Said Ram decided he was bored and
he yanked one off the jacked up.
Maintain his war was like,
dude, my Dick is the way
people lying in your calm deals.
That's so rude. And you know,
that happens all the time and that's
why I'm never doing a public. Okay,
well let me tell you something.
This tank unless, uh,
I need my shorts on breast from fucking
good morning America unless he's jacking
off in the tank. Right. He's the only
one who's been in it. Don't let it,
don't let this degenerate in there
because I'll tell you right now, Jamie,
this fucking guy was squeezed. Went off
right now. Please went off from tank.
So disrespectful.
I thought this was a big place.
I thought that they filter
the water comes out.
I don't like being naked in warm water
bro. Like it's super exotic to me.
She choke off before you go in there.
So you're not attempted does it?
They'll song floating. Yeah. What
if you're just jack went off first,
then you'll be like, man, I
wish I was horny right now.
He came out and he goes like this.
He's like, I'm like, what? He goes,
how was your thing? I go, it was
good. It was actually really amazing.
Kind of felt myself floating and I
kind of, he goes here, I jacked off.
I was like, Hey, we don't ruin it. I
know what to do, what you do with it.
Cause I just fucking chat that day.
Shooting a heavier,
she going to jump places. Never get
with me back to go into my siblings.
Docomo for skimmer.
Well the salt kills everything
but gee whiz. Oh whatever.
I don't, I don't want, I
don't want dead. Come on.
And you can chose fucking tub bro.
Well crashed a one time thing.
Shout out to the float lab of Venice,
California and now Westwood,
they uh,
they have the best tanks and he's
about his fucking filtration systems.
He uses water filtration systems for
like, like, like you'd use for a city,
this giant fucking machines.
You should see the setup he put back here.
It's like Commercial Waterford back here,
back here. They keep purpose tub bro.
They keep everything out.
Yeah. And we film, we feel,
we feel that
it is a one fucking type
thing. I was in the warm water.
I don't want to be naked. I get
it. I get it. I get it. Look,
anytime someone says
I was beaten off I go,
I get it to judged like your mother.
I don't want to be judged.
I get it. Let me too. People are
Gross, especially men especially,
uh, any other fights that we
should talk about the wrap this up.
It's going to get another shot at.
He should. Huh? You know what I mean?
This is what we're thinking and people
thinking, you know, the guy fights,
um,
wins more UFC title defenses than anybody
in the history of the sport becomes.
Uh, you know, the most accomplished
heavyweight of all time. I mean,
you think about what he's done.
Do you think about the fact that he
knocks out for BC over doomed to win the
title? He knocks out, asked
her over and defend the title,
knocks out Junior dos Santos stops beats
Francis when everybody's terrified of
Francis. I mean, he became
the most accomplished
heavyweight of all time. Right?
Then he gets knocked out
in the first round up.
Crazy perfect punch by Daniel Cormier
and a perfect strategy. He got to go.
Well, he, uh, for sure
I'd like to see a rematch.
It's like,
when do you want to see them beat
somebody first and then have a rematch?
I actually want to see,
but for me, Dan called me.
I've always said it is the most impressive
fighter to ever step in the octagon
in terms of his stature. I just
think he's incredible. Right?
He said to me the best,
I want to see him fight Jon Jones.
I know that John John's, they say,
well, the big money versus Brock,
that all he's waiting.
Okay,
so even with Alexander guts when
all this tool five talk, he's like,
you'll run mail. He's like,
well, that's not happening.
Yeah, I'm retiring in March,
Brock,
we ready to go.
Can you January person just asked for a
title shot now after he just beat Glover
and so you know, he said
something like, Hey, you know,
like I love the U of C's can be as Brock.
The fight is broad questions.
The narrative guys, Ken Brock,
pass tests. Look at me. Yeah, yeah.
You know,
how long do you need to go to last?
How long do you need before?
It's like the answer's never.
Brian Gustafson opens up on crazy
situation taking him off UFC two 27 years.
Well, what's, what happens, small
injuries say we'll talk about it. Oh,
he won't talk about it then
how is he opening up? Kit
will cause people are like,
oh you won't find Anthony Smith but you'll
fight DC or you'll find a heavyweight,
but now all of a sudden
you're injured and they fight.
Anthony Smith versus Shogun was a
fight that I was concerned about.
I thought shogun retired. Yeah.
However he won three in a row.
Few would have one that I wanted to see
him get a tough shot against DC cause I
went DC to get paid.
Well Shogun is,
he was ranked I think eighth,
eight or seven for this fight.
But even though he's not that old.
How old is Shogun?
Let's say you're 34 old though.
How old corridors and fight words?
He's just fucking Brazilian towards
the unibrow. How old is showing up?
I think he's like 36
right? He's my age. Izzy,
36 year old or even though he's
36 like look when Bernard Hopkins,
who 36 is when he knocked out
Tito Tryna dog. He's in his prime.
When he beat Kelly Pavlock he was,
I think he was close to
49 had been 42 and yeah,
so that's not a Kelly paddocks
killer. Yeah. Not for everybody.
It doesn't mean that
they're past their prime,
but shogun had been in so many wars and
he got knocked out by Dan Henderson and
the mainstay and brother and is different.
In 19 came on the Grand Prix
price days too. It was different.
Different world, different
world, the drugs and price.
And now we got the grant snitch. It's
such a different environment. Yeah, man.
But you'd never know who was doing what
back then when they were went there for
a mother. Fuck his mother.
He's a talent fucker.
Let's not just propel him
to fight Gus if, no, no, no,
no dude let but meet him while he was
ready. He was ready. He wanted to fight.
He looking.
Here's the argument for it.
The argument for it is he knocks
out Rashad on short notice.
He knocks out shogun and then he'll
say, look, I'll take this fight to,
that guy's rolling and he's a veteran.
He's got momentum. You don't know.
Fight the fight.
The most intriguing fight to me would be,
I mean it's not Brock and I liked that.
I liked PROC DC because DC gets paid,
but to me the only reason,
but the,
the most intriguing fight to me and a
lot of ways would be y'all out Romero at
two oh five and dealt with that weight
cut with Daniel Cormier as well.
Cormier was like, Nah, Nah, you can't
lose at this fight and you miss wait,
go. Yeah, sure. And you Ms. Wade
smart. But then Yo like listen DC,
you cheated when you made,
you know you're pushing
down that towel that one time. Okay,
that one time, that one time. Those real,
do we want to talk about cheating and
for ELL to DC? What are you saying?
Dual gate. Oh, still get,
here's the difference.
You fuck my boy Tim over the coaches.
You're saying the coaches,
John McCarthy said it totally different
when John McCarthy explained it to me
and I, I think he explained it to me
off the air. This is what was wrong.
The guy who put too much Vaseline
on on Yo el was not in his corner.
The guy was a UFC employee and he wasn't
coming back in and John was trying to
get them to come back in and he didn't
come back in and Yo al sat down on the
chair and he said if you had to do things
differently you would have done things
much differently. It would have
forced them off the chair now.
But he said this clusterfuck
could happen over 30 seconds.
Was is not because of Yo L's corner
cause because of the UFC employee.
Take back what I said, if, if John
says that what John says his word,
it's where I will not argue
with John McCarthy effort.
He explained it to me in no uncertain
terms. He said, but this man, he goes,
I feel like he got away with something.
He goes in and an ever every fight after
that I watched him like a hawk. He goes,
I felt like he got away with something
and that's like Tim over no matter what
the state on his stool, he did stay on
a stool. I mean there was no though.
If no one's getting this
too. I'm like, I'm chilling.
It was 30 seconds is is his significance.
It's huge. But then he had
a good, he had a good point.
I could everything that Tim,
Tim at one point was holding his wrist.
He had cuffed his glove.
He was holding his, well,
it happens in any industry fight,
right?
He hit him with a punch and that
was the punch that heard him. Yes.
So he has an argument. You're
right. It happens in every fight,
but it's not supposed to happen. Right.
It's not something you're supposed to do.
Now. Tim was in full barbaric
rage when this was happening.
When he's throwing his punches,
he recognized that he was grabbing,
he's fucking throwing bombs.
Who knows? What was that?
He's fighting with the most athletic
guy for sure. He's ever fought. I mean,
he was in a bad state in that fight.
I mean that was a like,
doesn't have like one to fighting
a guy. Jesus had one. Yeah.
Yo Man. Such a freak,
freak, freak, super freak.
Kelce Anderson twice in world champ. I
mean, he's super fruit. You're talking,
he's a freaking out. When I could find
all due respect. No, not a chance. Robert,
how dare you? I think you
went too. It'd be a draw.
Draw ten eight rounds if
you looked at it overall,
if he won two rounds, ten eight is
it a draw? Brian doesn't yell. Oh,
what were we saying round? He won
two rounds. Ten eight no, no, no.
Those round one round. One round tenants.
But it could be a draw at the end.
Both of those rounds, right? Yeah. But
one was like 10 when I'm like, damn,
it's ten eight so that'd be a drawing for
sure. But he didn't get it even in one,
which is what does an art,
that's a different guy.
It in two because in two rounds he had a
badly hurt. One was awful. Tone was off.
Eventually we'll talk tonight.
So let's say you give the one tonight.
So let's say it's a draw. Whatever Robert
work or the first one beat him, right?
Yes.
He did it with one leg and then this one
he'd beat him with one arm occur. No,
he broke his hand first.
That's right.
Straight up beast credible. One
leg. You're right. You're right.
That's a good vibe. Based on that
climbing on his jaw, you know,
Yo, I'll hit him with some
bombs. I don't have a problem.
Give them the ten eight on that guy's.
The fourth round.
Four thing was the fourth round
is a beast and still getting better.
Whitaker is only 26 here's
the problem though. He gets
injured all the time. Well,
who was he fighting? He's fighting
a brick wall. A brick wall twice.
Literally a brick wall. But the
problem is, is fighting so he can't,
you know what I'm saying?
So when you're going through
that rehabbing of broken bones,
you're not getting that much
better than between. Yes,
but it's entirely possible that with
a broken hand, he can work his kicks.
He could work a lot of different
things for sure. With a broken hand,
he's not going to have the same
issues that he had with a knee.
See what the knee you're,
you got mobility compromises.
You have a real hard time to train,
not train it with his hand.
He can do a lot of shit for sure. Yeah,
he's young and he could still, I mean,
look what he's doing in the fight. He
was throwing combinations with the left.
He was kicks. No, his kicks are
phenomenal. You all you want to fuck up?
I knew with this kid
fucked his knees and he fucked his
knees up really early in the fight.
Like right from the jump.
He was using that oblique kick
on the front leg side kick.
I got you oversee the
pos or Bonacina but Gina,
I would never wear those. If I had
a buddy lag then yeah, it cost,
they got mad at my boy, Kelly Slater.
Oh, why? Because Kelly was like, he,
I don't think you've passed the
sniff test. Oh, you mean as Kelly?
I mean the chances for a rematch for
that Whittaker and and Steven Thompson.
Well with Stephen Thompson
just lost till. So, um,
unless Stephen Thompson goes up to one 85,
I don't think it's going to happen
because Stephen Thompson is at one 70 and
could do it.
He could go up to one 85 in short though
the queue at welterweights a nightmare.
So if he wanted to get quick title shot,
he didn't that one on one.
He did knock rubber to cut her out. But
I think you can achieve with that. Yeah.
And you think you attribute some of
that to the brutal wait, cut. You know,
we're seeing these guys that are,
they're just taking so much out of
their body to get to one 70 this is why
people get so fucking angry when someone
misses weight by a couple of pounds and
still fights like Derek till.
So see,
here's the argument against Darren
till fighting for the title.
He Wa he beat Stephen Wonderboy.
But how many pounds over was he a lot?
It was more than two write way more. Yeah,
it was a six. It's criminal. It's a lot.
I don't think it was that much,
but it was a lot of weight.
It was more than two pounds.
That is a lot of weight to lose
when you already dried out.
And he's an enormous welter weight. So
the argument and she argument should be,
if we're in a fair world,
if you do not make weight and you win,
you cannot fight for the title
next, the problem. Right.
The problem with that is financially
that sucks because I want these guys to
fight. Sure. Right? And as a fan, it
sucks because I want these guys to fight.
But from the perspective of the
athletes, you've got to think like, man,
and so this brings me back
to my original premise.
I don't think they should
be able to cut weight.
I think what they're doing at one
fc and what Ben askern detailed,
how they monitored his weight cuts
move everybody's championship up await.
You keep the same champions.
You find out what fucking wait,
is that the right weight for them?
There was an idea if a sky 70 nope,
your real weight is one 85
if the guys want 85 people,
we would still people with Stella.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
They don't allow them to, they do
hydration test through their entire camp.
They checked him multiple times.
They find out exactly what they way
they find out what they really way plus
hydration test. Yes. They're not
cutting weight. That makes sense.
They go up,
you go up a weight class,
everyone just goes and astro went up to
one 85 he was fighting at one 70 before,
I think. Find that. Make,
make sure that's correct.
I know your body better for your career.
100% better.
He was one 17 but I believe they
made him go to give it a title,
but he kept his title.
So you don't strip the championships.
He just moved the champions up 100% and
I think they should establish additional
weight classes. So what does it say
here? Um, result, event day. Okay.
We will allow our athletes to come.
We will not allow our athletes to compete,
compete, dehydrated. Rich find said
powerful rich Franklin Franklin.
But if they happen to be overweight,
if they're hydrated,
but maybe half a pound over,
something like that,
we can negotiate a catch weight
and we have parameters for that.
We have to police to 105% of
their opponent's weight. Oh,
they have to be at least a hundred
per 5% of their opponent's weight,
so they can't be more than 5% over is
what he's saying. Damn. It's really smart.
Ingenious.
He said we use an instrument to test to
Pacific specific gravity of their urine,
which test, how much saw utes
are in their urine. He continued.
Obviously the more solid roots you have,
the more dehydrated you are.
So they have dehydration tests are the
established at a fighter is performing at
a healthy weight.
They weigh in at that weight.
They're weighing in it that way at a more
than one occasion. They're checking it.
It should be easier. In fact, he just,
he knows a lot about this tee shirt does.
He was enormous.
He was in [inaudible] 85 he was an
enormous one 85 when he was the champ.
He was so much bigger than like David
[inaudible] and a lot of the guys,
he knows a lot about wake up and he
was a fitness phenomenon. Math teacher.
He was like one of the guys that was
one of the first super fucking condition
guys who just break guys with his
pace and his will and his discipline.
He's a beast.
Rich Franklin does get enough credit.
He was an ass and cause we see
because we remember him from,
from the Dave Anderson Bites, really God
verse Franklin Minis. For most of us,
most of us are heard about him when, when
we saw him just have to deal with that,
that the best of all solvable problem.
But when Anderson Anderson back then,
his body though was this,
when he fought Anderson
at that point in time,
Anderson was the best of all. He was
a Ninja and they were like, rich,
we need you to financial against.
You need to do it again.
But we are doing since standing in
front of all your friends and family
[inaudible] he couldn't get out his nose.
Yeah,
rich Franklin's without time greats.
He's an all time because one
of the reasons I got into
it, but you know, Brown,
he didn't, he had a different strategy.
His strategy was to be super strong,
super condition. Very highly skilled,
but not at the same level of Anderson.
Anderson's thing was all
technical Anderson was all
about technique and footwork
and movement and he, that
trumps everything. It really
does. Nerd. I was like,
I tag us a Alva telling me that said,
he's like the dude. I was like, what?
Because you knew him really well.
Like what's it like?
He was a martial arts nerve martial
art nerd. He would like practice.
Remember that one weird thing where he
did his elbow up and when you freak out,
he'd not proud Tony for that.
Apparently according to Jack,
he had been practicing that. He
was always doing this like, well,
I wonder if this work. I mean, he's just
really Chris in this worse than this. His,
his fucking trainer told him to stop
doing it because it's not going to work.
Right. So he makes his wife hold
a pillow for him, so he goes home,
he's fucking blast in the
pillow with this upward elbow.
He does it over and over again and it
pulls it off in the fight and knock them
dead with it. It's a crazy scene. Yeah.
You ever see his fight with Lee Marie
and cage warriors now? Holy Shit.
Holy Shit.
He was going to retire to big nog domes.
Like you can't stop coming to the UFC. He
was catching his stride in England. See,
he fought very well in Japan, but then
really came into his own in England.
He fought Jorge Rivera. Do you remember
Jorge Rivera? He fought Jorge Rivera.
Jorge was teeing off on him.
Yeah.
He was letting Jorge punched him in the
face and then he fucked him up. Yup.
It was one of the scariest
fights I've ever seen him. Like,
I dunno what the fuck
he was doing back then,
but Anderson was on another guide,
wasn't like this crazy super.
He was, not that he was
retired. He was always skillful,
but it was never like crazy.
I was watching him fight from the fights
that I was watching from England, so I,
I would, you know, as a hardcore
fan, especially back then,
I knew that there was a lot of talent
that I wasn't seeing in the UFC when I was
working for the UFC.
So I was actively like trying to seek
out all the guys that people that would
hear about, and I remember watching some
of the Andersons fights, I was like, oh,
this guy's hit a new place
because you guys do that man,
you'll see a fighter and they're
really good. They're really good,
they're really good. And then all of
a sudden, boom, they hit that girl.
And if that,
some of that,
it's like sometimes there are certain
pockets of coaching that seemed like a New
Zealand New Zealand has high level strike,
I'll for sure with style bender and
with a, and even the doctor, right?
I mean Dan Hooker, like here's,
here's him versus what? Watch this.
He's like letting him hit him. Look
at this, he's holding onto him,
Jorge's hitting him and hitting up
look it up. Boom. And he's like, bitch,
this is not happening. You Ain't hurting
me. He's standing right in front of them.
I mean literally little let him punch him
in the face and just rolled with them.
Then how about when it comes to the
UFC, they're like, Hey Chris, leaving,
fight this Brazilian like what?
But it's crazy how calm he was while
Jorge was knocking people out, man,
that he has big power.
The fact that his and was so skillful,
he was really able to just turn his face
just slightly to standing and move with
those punches just enough to take the
pop off of them and completely ruined
confidence. And then he just
starts putting it on a man.
He just started putting
it on Prime Anderson.
You remember how electricity
was coming to the octagon? This,
this was a fight that really
turned it around from me.
This isn't the Lee Marie fight. There
were two fights where I was like, okay,
he's in a different place right now.
You know?
He just was so fucking talented and so
good at judging distance and figuring out
what to do and when to do it.
And he fought when he fought
Demian Maia and Abu Dhabi.
It was a boring ass [inaudible] fuck this.
But there was something in the first
round that he did where I was like, wait,
what?
He leaped and he hit Damien Maia with a
flying knee from about four or five feet
further away than I thought was possible.
Dude, I will. I will never forget.
I will launched himself
and it looked,
it didn't look like it was much effort.
Nothing went when he knocked out,
vetoed that fucking front kick man.
First time we were like kind of slung
get fucking starts from that main event.
I remember I was sitting
basically Kate's I,
my manager Lex with me and he has bad
eyes, basically blind. He can't see.
I was dying and it happens.
I go,
that's the craziest thing I've ever
seen in sports. It was what happened.
I know what you fucking misdiagnosis.
I didn't see it.
I didn't see. I'm like, I should
not be here. I love that dude.
You wasted this fucking ticket lakes. I
remember shut up. I remember screaming.
He fucked, kicked him in
the face. That was the,
that's the best sporting
event live I've ever seen.
When Anderson Silva kick fucking crazy.
It was just this stock and it was also
one of those fights where you didn't know
who the fuck was going to win that fight,
that fight.
Remembering what beat toward that was too.
That was pretty jacked up. He tour? No,
no, no. It was it between now
bodied up the way he was after.
It was like super easy. What
he looked like. Well he wasn't,
it wasn't Dan, but look at it. Look
at his body is nowhere near the veto.
That Rockhold fight. Dude. He looks
pretty good. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Watch the fight back it up a little bit.
Why watch them actually move around
before the knockout. That's all it is. No,
he wasn't. He was in bed.
Go to the way and he,
I remember very specifically that was
the same look that he had when he fought
like Takiyama or sexy young for sure,
which wasn't terrible was it was in
comparison to how he looked when he fought
Bisping. Look, there's the team.
We'll kick. Yeah, we'll give you,
Vito was a different detour. It's what is
this? Which one's, this Si very smooth.
This is not, he doesn't look anything
like TRT v two look at his neck.
Look at his body traps
are a little smaller.
Obviously he's still about 1400 grams.
Not even close to Jack though, right?
I mean he's in very good shape. Don't get
me wrong, but when he's not in TV tour,
you know who'd be DRTV tried his
prime hook. Jon Jones. Yes he did.
But Jon Jones is enormous.
So, oh look at this
thing with the hands.
Look at Anderson.
Anderson was doing like
wing Chung on him and shit.
I remember people were booing cause you
guys were just move around and were like,
come on,
let's do something then
hit cow. He's looking for the move,
man. He's looking for that opening.
He's looking for that opening
and he's smiling, smiling.
Look at watch them and look down too.
That's the other thing he did that old
move that guys would look down at your
feet and kicking the head was actually
six two or six. Three we think. Six.
Three I believe. Three tall. Yeah.
He almost got starched here. Two men.
Vito was throwing some fucking haymakers.
You're there on the ground.
He tours a monster, a monster.
See This v Tours, very fit,
very good in shape.
Veto, but not TRT v tour.
Once they gave him the green light and
then you'd have to worry about testing.
He was like, he put a thousand
horsepower engine in a Volkswagen,
drove off a cliff.
Let's do this.
Oh my God, whoa on Sun.
Came out of nowhere.
Then one to them. Look at that again.
Watch this. They did not need the one too,
but yeah, look how he's looking at his
chest too. Yeah. Toad deceptive. Yup.
He looked at his chest in front,
kicked him in the Chin and that was
literally the first time we'd ever seen a
front kick to the face.
All dropping.
There's only two moments that made my
jaw drop that Anthony Pettis German.
Remember when the Oda,
but cheated did the same thing to Randy
coture but he ended with a jumping front
knock his teeth.
Kid Karate kid is disrespectful and then,
and then Leo did it to fucking vittores
like this is your last full around.
This is why. Let me show you
something. Look at this same shit.
He's doing the fucking og.
That crazy little fact for you.
I got a look at that brand new.
We're ready for this fight.
The night before I told myths and Mimic
Leo Machida. One thing I didn't mimic.
Fucking God. Yeah, that was
the, Oh, is this too fast thing?
He kick his fucking too disrespectful.
That is. They know and I said,
Holy Shit. I go that he kicked a suit at
Dana goes, we'll buy him some more teeth.
And I said, dude, he's Randy. Go to her.
I want some shit with diamonds in it.
Get him some with diamonds. Awful. Insane.
When he locked up v
toward this last fight,
that's the worst front kick you've
ever seen. What was perfect?
It's a walk off home run and
this is what's disrespectful.
I know he's being polite.
He goes sketches and fucking be towards,
just falls down and gets on
his knees and pray. Watch this.
But watch how perfect it is
to watch a quick boop. Oh,
see like stands over and
then, yeah, my brother.
Thank you for your time in the cage.
Yeah,
I'd rather you just walk off and
jump on the cage with your ticket.
I know King Samurai he is,
that is a crazy front kick though.
And it's the same thing.
Well you know Leo and damaged and are
partners in crime act to back that up
again. Let me, let me see something
there. Oh, come on. How cool is this?
Your beat toss? Not, the cool
thing about the front kick is man,
if it's going to the face,
it's such a different thing
than if it's gone to the chest.
Don't bow to me like that FTE
fucking knocked my head off.
It's going to the chest you're
looking at like move away from that.
But it's going on the face and it's like,
it's not like a,
yeah. And a lot of times when
guys would take it to the body,
what they would do is kind of like
almost like move with it a little bit,
try to move with it, but that doesn't
help you if it goes up to your chin.
Liotta is just that career ender like
this is your last fight. Very cool. Randy,
check this out. This is your
last one. Let's try. This
was terrible. That was terrible. Munoz,
we need to take this fine short notes
and we've all been trained together.
Leo told me and what we're all trained,
the super jacked one to fly to London,
but look how yoga was then.
That was the oldest first spin at one 85
let's take a look at that again. Say it.
Yeah. He's a great guy. He didn't,
he had a perfect opportunity to him.
First of all,
those two are the best man.
I know that a vendor entered that right
man. They're both the or whatever.
A long time. If those were my training
partner. Damn, that's an amazing hand.
These guys here, the, I saw you roll with
that. Leo was such an unusual, finer,
so difficult to deal with. The
Nice, I remember four years ago,
three years ago when the
lock and we'd done trained,
just had this brutal training
session at blackouts and I go,
how much longer you to do this shit
man. And he goes, six years. I went,
the fuck it. You know you have six years.
Like we're like laughing. He's like,
well for sure I do. I'm to forget
as long as six. Yeah, he's,
well now he's in Beltour. He's like
legit marsh warranty. Yeah. Oh yeah.
He got a new warranty
function keys on van eyes.
You can keep it rolling.
It's chuck.
Is Chuck actually going to
fight Tito or is that kind of,
that's happening in golden boy.
What's going to happen though there?
They listened.
They said that it's going to happen,
but there's no venue picked out that he's
got to pass boards and a Dane is very,
very concerned about it. Yeah.
You know, a lot of people concern,
like Dana said publicly that he didn't,
I mean there's a reason why you asked
chuck to retire or nine years ago.
You know, he doesn't, he doesn't
think it's right and he wouldn't,
he wouldn't put the fight on himself.
I mean,
whoever would put the fight on would make
a shitload of money credit to them for
not wanting to do it. Cause Danny cares
about chuck. But Chuck wants a fight.
So who, yeah, how are you going to stay?
You got to stop him. He didn't stop.
If it goes down, I want to fight
and Oscar medically can magically.
The thing is the, the
whoever the board, I mean,
I don't know what his medical
condition is. You have to check.
You have to think of how do they check?
That's a good question.
We have cat scans.
You have I where they're
going to do it too.
Highly doubt they do
in la or cat or Nevada.
Anna cat on the Camden, New York. No,
it's gonna be on like an
Indian reservation or some
shit like Tacoma fucking
Indian reservation or
some shit. Right. Tacoma.
Is that real disrespectful?
He goes like Tacoma fucking
so
they'll do it.
That's what I was looking for.
Yeah. They'll do it. A Little Fox,
big fights of Fox with you know,
and obviously you know you're dealing
with Oscar de la Hoya has a long history
of promoting. He knows where he can get
away with what and what they can do,
but it's the thing is like will they do
that or will they give them some real
examinations and find out how Chuck's
doing and Hey, Tina is good to go,
good to go. He's been fighting recently.
He's been winning recently. Guy. He goes,
can you fine? You talked
to Tito. I talked to Tito,
real recent life teen on my
show like every week. He's
100% there. He's the best.
He's there. He's good
man. He's a good guy.
We have an impression of Tito that a lot
of it is based on his interactions with
other people, his fights. So stupid,
but also that that's a
product of the times with him
because he was this bad ass.
The Huntington beach bad boy. There was
no podcasting, there was no social media
podcasts. And so to know him know,
so Tino came on if Tito at the time,
as big as he is and he
can't on your podcast,
he had been even bigger cause you go,
oh my God,
that guy you did come on my podcast many,
many years ago,
but he'd already retired.
He retired.
I'm saying they've came and went during
its hay day, Sunny beach, bad boy.
And you were as big as you are now with
this podcast and you got his story out
while my God, well I mean you
have an idea who that person is.
Like Kevin Lee's a perfect example,
right? He got this great guy, super smart,
super tuned in, super ambitious fucking
amazing fighter and youngest shit. Yeah,
massive, massive potential. But
people saw him on the podcast,
got to hear him talk for three hours
and he's super honest about everything
about and articulate, articulate, smart,
outgoing, great control of his ego.
He's not, he's not a maniac.
He's a psych a really? Yeah.
Cause you get an and sound bytes,
you get such a different
impression of certain things,
especially in those interviews, man.
Those interviews at guys like Tony,
what you're gonna do to your opponent,
I'm gonna fuck him.
You're talking about why when I
rubbed off the scale and I'm like,
energizer is like, what are you gonna do
to him? You're all aggressive, you know,
playing a,
you who would I think
would grow even bigger as a
superstar if they did a pocket.
Your podcast. Who? Conor McGregor. Oh,
you have sat down with tell
cat while I'm just like, no,
I think you would get less hate. Obviously
he has all the accolades in the world,
but, and there's the s the stool
or the Dolly, all that shit.
But as a person and he sat
down and you talk to him,
you just didn't get all
that Hoopla over here.
And you sat down and talked to him. Oh,
I think you'd be. Even when he retired.
I don't get that. Why? We almost
did it before. There was some,
some trying to figure out times
like before he became gigantic,
before the Diaz fight, before he won
the title. There was some talk about it.
It just, you know what man?
For better or for worse,
I don't chase anybody and I
would definitely say no, no, no.
I'm not saying you are, but I'm saying,
I know there's some great guests.
Like I know, I know there's some people
that I would really like to get on,
but if it doesn't happen,
it doesn't happen.
I like having you guys on as much as I
like some scientist who flies in from
France. I really do. I just like, I
like talking to people that are fun.
Whether it's talking to you guys are
talking to whoever the fuck it is.
I would like to get Obama on one day.
I would like to talk to him.
You're getting huge.
Maybe I would like to talk to a lot of
people and she's like, take a Trump bump.
I would talk to him. Yeah. Why? Why not?
When are you going to get
real answers though? Cause
he's the president, you know,
you'll find out if you get real answers.
Did you talk to mayor? Have you,
have you talked to mom about when he
had Obama on net to submit a list of
question that the okay. The questions
and it goes and even, you know, he goes,
listen, it was great. I'm
glad to give him the time,
but that's not like a real podcast.
Right?
There can be an agenda and I can't
know what I'm going to ask you next.
I come home like when we come on here,
fight campaigns or our podcast,
I have no agenda. I have
no idea what we're going to
talk to you. They have to be,
they have to be concerned that you're
gonna set them up and make them look bad.
There's so much on the line for
everything. And when Obama was doing this,
Obama was a sitting president. He
was about to leave office. You know,
and they probably had very
strict rules in terms of what,
what they would allow and not
allow in terms of interviews.
And this isn't the platform for him.
He thinks Trump doesn't
give a fuck about all that.
I guarantee you he would be more confident
and more open to just being able to
figure his way through it
because he wouldn't worry about,
he doesn't prepare first and also wouldn't
worry about me outmaneuvering him.
Like he's not, he's not the
smart dude, but also, have
you ever heard Trump before?
He was present on Stern. Yeah. There's
some of the greatest interviews.
He's hilarious. Well, he was great
and, but even, but he's also older,
you know,
and then also the pressure that Gig and
then the pressure of everybody hating
him. Yeah. You know, the whole thing
is fine. And I'm not saying this,
that he's the greatest guy in the world,
but I'm saying the whole thing is insane.
Nobody should be president
fucking thankless job.
Nobody shouldn't have that kind of power.
And it's such a dumb move to take
that Gig at 70 it seems to me in such
decision, you make you piss off 50%
of the people and you make 50% no,
you're not going to win.
How much time do you have left?
What do you have 20 years left?
If every cherry on the Sundae for a guy
like that was accomplished with his ego,
but also to say, hey, you have four years
to accomplish all this. I fuck for him.
Do you know who that John Luca Vivace
guy is? He's that a Italian guy.
He's a, he does a lot of dancing on
the Instagram super millionaire guy.
Go to his, his Instagram.
He's got a patio in shape.
He's got a video of him dancing
and there's all of these, uh,
girls with thought behind him,
bent over with their ass up in the air.
So He's a Italian.
That's him.
We're supposed to be doing
when you've got Trump money,
what Trump's should be doing is fucking
be half naked by the pool dancing in
front of book. I guess
sternness, look at this.
I'm watching to watch this real quick.
This is what if I was,
if I was friends with Trump, I would
say, listen, Bro. Powerful one.
If we had bike, this guy, he's
my, he's younger than me, so
he's not, no, he's not. No.
Brian, he's older than
you. He's 50 50 yeah, he's,
he's in the neighborhood.
Oh, so you can't haul,
he's a little wrinkle because
he's in the sun every day,
but meanwhile he's doing this every day
to look at is awesome. Ankle bracelets,
dude. Look at the bitches in the back.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, this is the point.
This is what I would tell
Trump to be doing. Do this.
And then La Loche watch the girls behind
them. Those hard life goals. However,
that's how I see. I see a lonely
man. I think you're wrong. Look,
he's happy. He's happy as shit. He's
always laughing, always smiling.
Either it's a tremendous act
or he is actually a happy,
rich guys banging tens over
the world and he's doing, he's,
he's working as a Dj everywhere and he's
got all these videos of him having a
great time. Oh Wow. Dude.
Would you rather be him or Trump?
That's what I'm saying.
This guy's having a great time
with his money. All these people,
it's all love and happiness
is jetting all over the world.
I'd have to say on stand up please.
Elan Musk take notes. Pro Trump is just,
you know, he's a guy wanted to
win. Look at hyster steel. Yo,
come look at that outfit. Get some fucking
tattoos and computers and tats salary.
Like somebody just wrote on
him when got your marker,
but he's got some bad tattoos too.
He's got a picture of his face on
his back going like this. Shush.
It's the shut the fuck up tattoo.
He says it's a, it's a very, very,
it's a very unfortunate tattoo. We are
Billy and you do where the fuck you. Yeah,
this is him.
[inaudible]
Hashtag [inaudible] Hashtag [inaudible]
and pimping all over the world.
Hashtag g g lifestyle. He's got it
tattooed on his leg. That's aggressive.
But when your ability to,
oh, he's got water there.
You want to just love on his right tit
because you need love and you're right it
dude, he's kind of killed
it. This is the thing, man.
This guy smiling every time I see Trump,
he's got a bigger and bigger frown and
he's aging course agent like fruit,
aging fruit.
Yeah.
It's not a fine wine cheese.
The fucking most recent Cohen tapes,
Cohen's releasing tapes now
of him negotiating about
the paying off a Gal. Yeah,
well they,
they seize those tapes.
How was not cones in the
system sees the nine tapes,
I believe. Just, Oh,
they definitely did that,
but I believe they said that Cohen
released them to CNN. Is that true?
See if that's true. Did you see that?
His wife got busted watching CNN.
He freaked out. She was on Air Force
One watching CNN just hating on them.
They call it hate watching. She doesn't
mean he wasn't enjoying them. Come on.
She's got a tough when when the stormy
Daniels and the other one comes out,
you know, dude, you know what?
That's true. Who's fucking her?
Where's that dude?
She's a beautiful,
well she's probably keeping
it together for a kid, man.
She's got a 10 year old kid.
Here it is.
Donald Trump erupted with
rage from Melanie's air force.
One TV was tuned to CNN says leaked email.
How crazy.
The president is in a battle with CNN.
That is so kind of winning.
I'm saying kind of winning.
Well definitely 100% done is damaged
their reputation among the young people
kind of dessert sometimes like some
of the mainstream media deserves.
Because what happens now is to
stay in business, they've got it.
They've got to create click bait shit,
head White House bands,
network pool from Rose Garden event.
Who's this?
She asked him about the
colon tapes and hey,
she got banned from you can get
banned if you ask them questions.
How does that work? Do you have
the z? Like he's Marin Cherry.
You have the fucking list of questions.
Always reserve the right to sort of,
you're invited into the press
pool I believe. And, uh,
I think until there's been that sort of
a depressant progress there all these
little sneaky,
it'll be a little sneaky things that the
executive power has that that's kind of
granted to the executive. The craziest
one is the pardon thing. You can go again.
They killed a bunch of
people, Brian, but I like you.
We like smoke stove used together. Yup.
Did you guys listen to 'em? I admit it.
The new r Kelly, 19 minutes saw
having, I've heard it's amazing.
Is it because he talks about he
basically a 14 girl and got away with it
there. That's supposedly what
happened. Yeah, but does he
admit a lot of it? I mean,
no, he doesn't admit peanut
anybody or that the video was him.
What's he admit?
He admitted it's,
it's most of the song is just him talking
about all the chicks he banged and
about how they took all
his money because the,
they made them sign contracts when he
was young and he was dyslexic and he
couldn't read gateway.
All the rights to his music and talking
about all flaws that he has and how many
girls he lied to and how many girls he
banged and goes over all that stuff.
So that whole story about
him with the young girl with
wait who said that? Who said that? I
don't know. He got her off. It'd be,
and I know that he was with a 14 year old.
What was that?
Lists some just to get someone gets
off or a jury of their peers doesn't
convince you me off. I
thought, who the fuck knows?
But it does not mean that he didn't
do it. Know? Have you seen the video?
It looks like, yeah. No, no.
I watched them piss on a curl.
It certainly looks like it. Here
it goes. Start Kelly secretly.
Mary's 15 year old Aaliyah 22
years ago today. Yeah, that
was it. No, no, that was a,
that was a singer. I know. That was a
different thing. That's in the song too.
Yeah. Well that alone is illegal
in a lot of places, right?
It's also some place they legally
everywhere in the United States today.
I think 16 in Vegas is 22 years ago
though. Was it? Cause that's what it was.
I think it was always 16 right?
I think 15 seems very young.
They kept that under wraps.
So that wasn't public knowledge.
I think the age of consent varies in the
states and has been different over the
last couple of decades.
And I think 22 years ago what he did,
I don't think it was illegal. What does it
mean? Is it Mexico? 14 in Mexico, Mexico,
Mexico, Mexico. Mexico is probably
real young. Is that where he did it?
I thought I was 14 I would
imagine if for could be. Well,
that's a weird thing, right? Like if
it's illegal in the United States,
but it's legal somewhere else.
If you go to Japan or wherever the fuck
it's legal and you get married and then
you come back to the states,
can you live as a husband and wife?
How the fuck does that work?
When I was 12 in Mexico,
it's as low as 12 well maybe as
low as 12 can I get a whoop, whoop.
So, well, but why? You know,
why don't you know we need
to incorporate them. Stop.
Just tell Mexico for us and
we're going to make drugs, legal.
[inaudible] we're going to pull the all
the troops out of Afghanistan and Iraq.
We're not Mexico cleanup all
the drug cartel bullshit.
But let's cut off the 12 year old shit.
Let's just stop all that.
You want to make a beat? 18. Jesus Christ.
We're neighbors. Keep it respectable.
Keep it respectable. [inaudible]
not good. Oh boop. Brian Callan,
congratulations on your special. I know
you worked very, very hard for this.
I'm very proud of you and I, I was, it
was awesome to see you gear up for it.
See how fucking fired up you got. And you
were doing a lot of touring and a new,
you were constantly doing sets around
town and constantly writing on it and
working on it and tweaking on it.
You could tell you tell you were really
obsessed with it, man. Thank you man.
It's the best thing I ever did. So
I'm, I'm happy. Better be Jesus Christ.
I'm just kidding. Christ. Um, so
when you do, now you're going to,
so now it's being edited and then
you get to rush shop shit, shop.
Take some time now. Take some openings.
You have one more shy. Just hit you.
You don't have the whole rest of the
year off standup because, uh, uh,
October, we're doing that big show with
all things comedy festival. You feel me?
Feel Oh shit.
[inaudible] fair and big.
Jay [inaudible] he's doing a festival.
Oh Shit.
We're doing one show on a Saturday night.
The weekend before Halloween in Phoenix
and Phoenix. One show went on sale.
That's amazing. It doesn't matter. You're
in it. That's beautiful. Right? All right,
boy, you have to be fun. This is fun.
My best man. But you're the best.
You're the best. Austin Dallas
first, uh, weekends in August.
US website website for [inaudible] dot
com slash [inaudible] 15 Vancouver them
by everybody.
It's always so much fun.